51 Spiele in 10 Städten, jetzt ist sie vorbei. Die Männer-Europameisterschaft 2024. Nein, vorbei ist sie noch lange nicht. Erst wenn das Tribünengespräch dazu erscheint und der sportliche Rückblick, dann ist so ein Turnier abgeschlossen. Die Profis unter euch, die wissen es schon. Und damit Hallo und herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk. Wir sprechen heute über die Eindrücke bei dieser EM und von dieser EM aus der Journalistenperspektive, aus der Perspektive der Fans und aus der Perspektive von Volunteers und los geht's. Das Publikum der Rasenfunk.
The host of the Euro 224 will be Germany.
Recycling und Nachhaltigkeit, es war das große Thema dieser Europameisterschaft, deswegen fand ich nichts passender als diesen O-Ton noch mal zu Recycle. Matthias Friebe vom Deutschlandfunk, erkannte ihn schon gut, denn auch als wir uns über die EM-Kosten hier im Tribünengespräch unterhalten haben, war er genau dieser Jingle zu hören. Matthias, schön, dass du da bist. Wie viele Spiele, in wie vielen Städten hast du denn gesehen bei dieser Europameisterschaft?
Erstmal danke für die Einladung. Ich habe zwölf Spiele gesehen und das hat sich so über die EM ein bisschen entwickelt. Ich wusste am Anfang gar nicht, wie viele es werden. Und dann habe ich irgendwann den Ehrgeiz entwickelt, in alle zehn Stadien zu kommen und habe das dann tatsächlich beim Viertelfinale auch komplettiert. Also zwölf Spiele in zehn Stadien.
Stark. Und wenn wir bei Ehrgeiz sind, in alle Stadien zu kommen, dann sind wir genau richtig bei Tobi Rieger. Expertinnen und Experten unter den Rasenfunk-Hörern, die werden sich erinnern, wir hatten diese Konstellation schon mal bei der EM 2016. Tobi, ich weiß gar nicht mal, wie viele Spiele du damals hattest. Vielleicht kannst du dich noch erinnern, wie viele waren es denn jetzt bei dieser EM?
Also ich kann mich sowohl daran erinnern, dass es damals elf waren, als auch, dass du das Intro damals als das längste Rasenfunk-Intro aller Zeiten genannt hast. Ja, ist kein Witz. Und heute hast du einfach recycelt. Aber wie du sagst, es passt sehr gut zum Turnier. Und tatsächlich waren es dieses Jahr 21 Spiele in zehn Stadien.
21 Spiele, das ist schon wirklich ganz fantastisch. Und jetzt bin ich gespannt, was uns Joel Guyot erzählt. Er war in der letzten Sendung noch nicht mit dabei, denn da war er noch gar nicht als Volontier unterwegs. Joel, ich freue mich sehr, dass du jetzt hier mit dabei bist, um uns die Sicht eines Volontiers auf dieses Turnier zu bringen. Ich hoffe, du verzeihst mir, ich habe deinen Nachnamen doch gebudgert. Ich habe es nicht. Guyot wäre richtig gewesen. Schön, dass du da bist, Joel.
Ja, ich war nicht so viel unterwegs. Ich war nur bei sechs Spielen in einem Stadion. Als Volontier zwangsläufig war ich quasi nur hier in München unterwegs. Mehr konnte ich neben meinem Hauptberuf und meiner Tätigkeit als Aushilfstrainer bei der D-Jugend hier meiner Tochter nicht unterbringen.
Ja, das muss ja auch nicht schlimm sein. Aber dann stelle ich doch gleich mal die offensichtliche Frage, die glaube ich auch allen Hörern und Hörern unter den Nägeln brennt. Wie viel hast du denn von den Spielen dann eigentlich gesehen?
Relativ viel. Ich glaube, ich habe nur von einem Spiel fast nichts gesehen bzw. nur am Fernsehen, im Stadion, im Bauch des Stadions. Das war das Spiel, wo wir uns auch gesehen haben. Es müsste Rumänien-Ukraine gewesen sein. Da war ich im Presseraum und stand quasi nur die ganze Zeit im Presseraum unten. Ich bin nur ab und an mal auf die Tribüne oder an die Eckfahne gekommen. Mehr durfte ich nicht. Aber alle anderen Spiele habe ich oben von der Presse-Tribüne aus eigentlich ganz gut gesehen.
Und an wie vielen Tagen würdest du sagen, warst du jetzt für diese Europameisterschaft im Einsatz? Weil wir anderen haben zwar mehr Stadion gesehen, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass du die meisten Einsatzzeiten hattest.
Ja, das kann eventuell sein. Ich habe ja schon am 15. Mai gestartet mit meiner Voluntiertätigkeit. Ich war hier in München in der Akkreditierung tätig. Und die Akkreditierung startet, wie immer, bei diesen Turnieren quasi als Erstes. Und somit haben wir am 15. Mai die Schulung gehabt. Am 16. Mai haben wir die ersten Akkreditierungen ausgegeben.
Das ist einiges. Ich sehe schon den Gesichtern von Tobi und Matthias an. Und das Ganze ja neben deinem Beruf und neben allen anderen Tätigkeiten, da musst du uns gleich noch mehr drüber erzählen. Aber da muss ich jetzt Matthias fragen aus Journalistensicht, ist quasi das das Wort, bei dem manche inklusive mir aufstehende Armhaare bekommen, ist gefallen. Akkreditierung und Akkreditierungscenter. Matthias, wie viele Versuche hast du gebraucht, um deine Akkreditierung zu bekommen? Und wenn du jetzt einen sagst, dann schreie ich.
Haltet euch mal die Ohren zu. Also es ging tatsächlich problemlos, aber ich hatte auch kein Problem mit irgendwelchen zweiten Vornamen. Das habe ich so oft gehört, dass zweite und dritte Vornamen oder falsche oder andere Schreibweisen zu größeren Problemen gekommen sind. Also bei mir war es tatsächlich ein Versuch und irgendwann zwei Wochen vor dem ersten Spiel im Kölner Akkreditierungscenter ging ganz gut. Aber bevor du jetzt weiterfragst, du hast überhaupt nicht gesagt, in wie viel Stadien du warst.
Oh Gott. Na toll. Ich habe mich nicht vorbereitet auf meine eigene Frage. Also ich war bei 15 Spielen in sechs Stadien, denn ich war nicht in Leipzig, Hamburg, Gelsenkirchen, Düsseldorf. Aber Joel, kannst du uns mal erklären, das ist jetzt natürlich nur so ein Nebenthema, aber Akkreditierung, das war ein großer Aufreger, auch hier im Rasenfunk. Ich meine, du hast mich ja quasi hands-on begleitet, bis ich dann endlich meine Akkreditierung in den Händen halten konnte. Warum war denn das so ein Durcheinander? Hast du das so schon mal erlebt? Denn du bist ja auch manchmal beim FC Bayern eingebunden.
Ja, ich bin ja quasi auch ein Akkreditierungsspezialist mittlerweile. Ich mache öfter das Volotieren und ich war schon bei der WM 2006 ein Akkreditierungsvolontier. Ich war auch bei der letzten EM hier Akkreditierungsvolontier. Da habe ich Matthias akkreditiert, der damals auch ein kleines Problem hatte.
Da hatte ich Probleme.
Genau, ja. Genau, wir kennen uns schon. Deshalb mache ich das Akkreditieren ja auch. Jeder muss an mir vorbei. Nein, das war in diesem Fall tatsächlich so, dass die Uefa noch strengere Regeln aufgestellt hat als bei den Turnieren zuvor. Und sie wirklich, jeden Akzent, jedes kleines Häkchen, das auf den Namen irgendwie war, wenn es im Ausweis oder Pass zu sehen ist, Binde, Strich, was auch immer, muss es in der Akkreditierung auch drin sein. Dann durchläuft das ein Security-Check, die Polizei der Schweiz macht dann hier Sicherheitschecks zusammen mit der deutschen Polizei. Und wenn das durchgelaufen ist, dann gibt es die Akkreditierung. Wenn nun aber jemand kommt und eben sein zweiter Vorname wurde nicht eingegeben, dann ist er zwar durch diesen Security-Check gelaufen, wurde er aber nicht akzeptiert. Und dann muss es noch mal durchgehen. Und das hat ziemlich viele Probleme gebracht.
Bei mir war es ja so, ich habe über vier Wochen hinweg viele E-Mails mit der Uefa ausgetauscht. Bei mir lag es aber gar nicht am Bindestrich oder am C. Ich ging einfach nicht durch die Sicherheitsprüfung, weil ich einfach so ein böser Bube bin, ganz offenbar. Da gab es so viel zu finden. Da hatten sämtliche LKAs anscheinend sehr viel zu tun. Aber als ich dann zwei Tage vor dem Eröffnungsspiel zum Akkreditierungscenter gegangen bin, mit der Mail von der Uefa, die gesagt hat, du gehst da jetzt hin und du gehst da nicht mehr weg, bis du die kriegst und dann wird das schon irgendwie klappen. Wir kriegen das irgendwie hin. Da warst du mir das, der mir das erzählt hat, oder jemand anderes vor Ort, der war richtig entspannt, als ich gemeint habe, ja, hier, ich brauche noch mal eine Akkreditierung. Ich weiß, ich habe viele solche Probleme, weil er gesagt hat, du, gestern kamen 20 ungerische Journalisten, bei denen hat nichts gestimmt, keins der Sonderzeichen. Und wenn wir das geschafft haben, dann schaffen wir dich auch noch. Also das waren die Extremfälle dann, die ihr hattet.
Es gibt ja manche, die dann gleicher sind als andere. Und wo das dann durchaus funktioniert, ohne noch mal eine Sonderschleife zu drehen.
Aber Karl-Heinz Rummenigge hat auch gar keinen Akzent in seinem Namen.
Bei dem nicht. Okay, jetzt plaudere ich wirklich aus dem Nähkästchen. Es sollen am Eröffnungsspieltag französische Journalisten gekommen sein, denen ein Akzent im Vornamen fehlte und die das Glück hatten, dass sie einen Ex-Profi-Fußballer von Bayern München dabei hatten. Und dann kann es sein, dass ich dafür gesorgt habe, dass die Akkreditierung ausgedruckt wird und ausgehändigt wird, ohne dass wir die nochmal zurückschicken.
Das heißt, ich hätte einfach nur ein Bayern-Spiel am Schlepptau mit dabei haben müssen und dann hätte ich schon am 16. Mai, oder wann ich da war, meine Akkreditierung.
Ja, bei dir funktionierte das leider nicht, weil ja wirklich ein Problem im Datensatz war und dadurch ging das nicht. Aber wenn deine Akkreditierung auf Grün-Conferb gewesen wäre und dann noch ein kleines Problemchen gewesen wäre, hätte ich natürlich das so hingedreht, dass du sie bekommst, ohne es den anderen zu sagen. Das ist dann halt die Schwierigkeit. Normalerweise werden die Akkreditierungen dann auch im Vier- bis Sechs-Augen-Prinzip gemacht. Das heißt, einer am Welcome-Desk prüft die Daten, schickt es weiter zum Druck. Die am Druck gucken nach und dann beim Ausländigen der Akkreditierungen ist eben der Zweite oder Dritte in der Reihe, der die Daten noch mal checkt. Deshalb muss man jedes Mal seinen Ausweis zeigen. Und da kann man eben nicht durchlassen. Da muss man dann schon kreativ dafür sorgen, dass nur eine Person das macht.
Ich will gar nicht wissen, wie du da vom Drucker zum Service-Test gelaufen bist und immer nur Cappy einmal verkehrt rum aufgesetzt hast.
Ich habe natürlich dann diesen ex-französischen Nationalspieler dafür genutzt, dass er Fotos mit den anderen Voluteers gemacht hat, verbotenerweise, und dadurch ihren Posten verlassen haben. Und ich habe ihren Posten übernommen.
Das ist ja wie ein Heißfilm hier.
Jetzt habe ich meine Chancen auf zukünftige Tätigkeiten bei der Uefa. Aber ich glaube, wir kriegen so schnell kein Turnier mehr in Deutschland. Und da bin ich da eh raus.
Ja, Tempensieg-Finale hättest du natürlich noch abgreifen können.
Ja, da komme ich ja sowieso hin in meiner zweiten Tätigkeit.
Ah, okay. Ich sehe schon. Matthias, du warst ja jetzt schon bei mehreren Turnieren. Für mich warst du das Erste und sehr wahrscheinlich auch vorerst das Letzte. Das hat halt einfach gut gepasst mit dem Turnier im eigenen Land. Aber ist das jetzt etwas Besonderes gewesen, dass es so genau war bei diesem Turnier und dass es auch so viele Probleme gab? Was hast du bei Kolleginnen und Kollegen gehört?
Ich habe tatsächlich diese, diese Namensgeschichten, über die ihr gerade gesprochen habt, habe ich auch ganz oft gehört. Bei mir gab es bis jetzt keine größeren Probleme. Das, was Joel gerade gesagt hat von der letzten Europameisterschaft, war eigentlich kein Problem. Das war eigentlich nur meine Dummheit, muss man sagen. Ich hatte bei der Akkreditierung meinen Reisepass angegeben. Weil das irgendwie so voreingestellt war von dem letzten Turnier oder wie auch immer, als ich zu dem Reisepass kam, keine Ahnung, und bin mit Personalausweis angereist. Das ist natürlich schwierig dann. Dann musste das kurz umgetragen werden, noch mal Sicherheitsüberprüfung, halbe Stunde später. Dank der tatkräftigen Unterstützung von Volunteers im Akkreditierungscenter ging das dann ganz gut. Ansonsten habe ich das Glück, dass ich mit der ARD zusammen akkreditiert werde im großen ARD-Team. Das heißt, ich fülle sozusagen ARD intern ein Formular aus und werde dann durch die ARD, durch diesen Prozess geführt und kriege am Ende die Mail von der Uefa, mit der ich dann dahin gehen kann. Von daher habe ich möglicherweise eine Luxussituation. Aber die Probleme, die andere hatten, habe ich tatsächlich auch häufiger gehört. Also dieses Mal waren sie wohl, was Namen angeht, besonders penibel.
Aber warum eigentlich? Also sind das Sicherheitsbedenken oder geht es darum, ich habe gehört, dass die Strafen, Joel, du kannst dich äußern, du musst dich nicht äußern, aber die Strafen für falsch ausgestellte Akkreditierungen oder eben fehlerhaft ausgestellte Akkreditierungen, dass die durchaus gar nicht so gering gewesen sein sollen, von der Uefa an den veranstaltenden Verband.
Ja, ich glaube, dass das, ich sage mal so, wenn man jetzt mal, es gab ja, ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele mich überhaupt mal interessieren, Joel, wie viele Akkreditierungen da so über euren Tisch gehen. Da ist ja wirklich jeder akkreditiert bis hin zum Einlauf-Fahnen-Träger oder Trägerin. Bei Journalisten gab es ja dieses Handbuch, was wir so dürfen und was wir so nicht dürfen. Und da waren ja so krasse Regeln drin. Und ich hatte das Gefühl, die allermeisten davon stehen auf dem Papier, sind aber im Alltag jetzt nicht so richtig im Einsatz. Also, weiß nicht, ob es euch anders ging. Also, dass wir jetzt nicht in der Mixed Zone irgendwie Selfies machen, ist irgendwie sowieso klar. Auf die Idee würde ich jetzt auch nicht kommen. Aber...
Es soll Leute gegeben haben, die haben da eine ganze Sendung aufgenommen. Das finde ich unmöglich, so was.
Weiß ich auch nicht, wer das gewesen sein könnte. Da stand ja aber zum Beispiel drin, dass man ohne Tribünenkarte nur mit der Akkreditierung gar nicht ins Stadion reinkommt. War jetzt nicht so schwer, mit Akkreditierung ins Stadion zu kommen. Hat sich auch niemand beschwert oder irgendwie gesagt, nee, Moment mal, geht gar nicht. Also, ich habe zumindest immer den grünen Haken ganz schnell bekommen.
Und Joel, willst du was sagen? Also, die Strafen für den Verlust der Akkreditierung für uns Journalistinnen und Journalisten war schon saftig, 150 Euro, der Verlust.
Aber das galt auch für uns Volunteers, also so ist es nicht. Aber nee, von den Strafen weiß ich jetzt, die Uefa dem Ausrichter vorgibt, weiß ich nichts. Aber ja, akkreditiert werden wirklich alle, von der Putzfrau bis, keine Ahnung, zum Bundespräsidenten. Jeder bekommt eine Akkreditierung. Das waren, wenn ich die Zahlen richtig in Erinnerung habe, über 200.000 Leute. Also es ist schon eine Menge. Wir haben in unserem Akkreditierungscenter vor dem Eröffnungsspiel an Matchday minus 1 und Matchday knappe 6,5 bis 7.000 Akkreditierungen ausgestellt.
Gott sei Dank war ich ja am Mittwoch noch da. Matchday minus 2 für alle Expertinnen und Experten. Da habe ich ja gerade noch alles richtig gemacht. Tobi, wenn du das alles hörst, wie froh bist du, dich nicht akkreditieren zu müssen, sondern einfach auf einem Weg, den du uns jetzt aber gleich erklären musst, bitte. Einfach so an 23. Waren es jetzt 23 Spiele? Ich habe es schon wieder vergessen, aber es waren 21.
Es waren am Ende 21. Geplant waren 23. Aber mich hatte nach dem ersten Wochenende, was auch immer, sagen wir mal, es war Corona, vielleicht war es auch irgendwas anderes, ins Bett gefesselt und hat mich zwei Spiele gekostet tatsächlich, die am Ende aus 23 dann nur 21 Spiele gemacht haben.
Aber wie war denn das bitte zu schaffen? Denn ich weiß nicht, wie es den anderen beiden geht, aber ich habe auch versucht, Privatkarten zu bekommen und ich war in diesen ganzen Warteräumen und so weiter und so fort und das war aussichtsloser als Kiel an Mbappé in der Mixtone in den Rasenfunk zu holen.
Hat das nicht geklappt bei dir mit Kiel an Mbappé? Also die Frage haben mich natürlich in den letzten vier Wochen viele Leute gefragt, weil du kommst natürlich vor Ort mit Leuten in Gespräche. Wie viel Spiel hast du gesehen? Wie viel siehst du noch und so. Ja, es ist eine Mischung aus Fleiß, guter Vorbereitung und natürlich auch viel Glück. Also da bin ich ganz ehrlich, es geht los mit dieser ersten Verkaufsphase. Irgendwann dritte Zehnte, glaube ich, zum Tag der Deutschen Einheit ging das los. Da konnte man sich bewerben. Ich habe die ganze Familie heiß gemacht. Ich habe gesagt, Leute, ihr müsst euch alle bewerben. Dann haben sich alle beworben. Da sind dann, ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele es am Ende waren. Ich glaube, für zwölf Spiele oder so sind Tickets abgefallen.
Wie groß ist denn deine Familie?
Du kannst dich ja bewerben auf jeden Spieltag einspiel. Also beim Öffnungsspiel ist nur ein Spiel. Das ist einfach. Beim zweiten Tag sind drei Spiele usw. Da gab es Tage, wo nur zwei Spiele waren. Immer auf ein Spiel. Das heißt, jede Bewerbung geht ungefähr raus mit 22. So viele Spieltage waren es, glaube ich, am Ende Spiele. Und dann das Ganze mal Familie geteilt durch Uefa, Zuteilungskoeffizienzen, mal Glück, minus ein bisschen, weiß ich nicht was. Da sind ein paar Karten bei rüber gekommen, sagen wir mal so. Und das war so ein Start. Und ich bin ganz ehrlich, als ich das gemacht habe, letztes Jahr im Oktober, ich hatte schon Bock aufs Turnier. Ich hatte auf jeden Fall mehr Bock aufs Turnier, als auf die Nationalmannschaft durch Deutsche und dachte, ja komm, guckst du mal ein bisschen, vielleicht fährst du ein bisschen durchs Land, guckst du ein paar Spiele an. Die Stadien kennst du jetzt auch schon alle, natürlich durch Bundesliga und Zweitliga-Betrieb. Aber irgendwie ist es ja auch was Besonderes, ziehst du durch. Und dann kam diese erste Zuteilung, die war durchaus erfolgreich. Und da bin ich noch in einem Forum in diesem Internet, wo sehr viele Menschen sind, die das gleiche Interesse haben, nämlich möglichst viele Fußballspiele zu sehen bei so einer Euro. Und dann tauscht du und dann guckst du.
Kannst du den Namen sagen oder ist es abträglich?
Ich würde, also könnte sein, dass ich danach da nicht mehr in dem Forum bin. Deshalb würde ich an dieser Stelle tatsächlich gerne darauf verzichten. Es ist wirklich, es gibt da, das ist ein bisschen kompliziertere Ort. Also es ist ein guter Ort, es ist wirklich ein Ort voller Vertrauen. Also wenn man parallel in irgendwelche Facebook-Gruppen oder sonst irgendwelche Sachen im Internet guckt, wo dann Karten angeboten werden. Du kannst halt davon ausgehen, du wirst abgezogen und das Geld ist weg. Ich habe Leute erlebt, denen das genau passiert ist. Denen passiert das in der Bundesliga, denen ist das zu Euro passiert. Und das passiert in diesem Forum halt nicht. Also das ist eine gewachsene Community. Ich war da schon, wer die Folge von dir, vom Rasenfunk, gerne nochmal nachholen möchte. Ich war da vor acht Jahren auch schon drin, bin da weiter am Ball geblieben. Und das hat sich definitiv gelohnt. Also man knüpft Kontakte, man findet vertrauenswürdige Leute und kann dann halt tauschen. Also ich habe zwei Karten für das Spiel über, kannst du mir zwei geben, dann kann ich. Und so erweitert man dann am Ende seine Spiele, die man hat. Und dann hatte ich noch relativ viel Glück beim Vorverkauf der Fußballnation, also des DFBs über diese Turniermitgliedschaft, die ich abgeschlossen habe. Auch da, wer nochmal zurückhören möchte, vor acht Jahren war ich noch Mitglied im Fanclub Nationalmannschaft. Das habe ich während der Sendung gekündigt und nie wieder aktiviert. Bin dann aber zur Turniermitgliedschaft 2024 beim DFB aktiv geworden. Dann kriegst du so ein Code zugeschickt. Und dann gibt es einen Moment X, wo man dann Karten kaufen kann über diesen Code. Natürlich auch aufgestaffelt nach Mitgliedschaftsdauer, nach irgendeinem Punktesystem. Ich war natürlich in der letzten Rutsche. Aber nachdem das geklappt hat und ich für die drei Deutschland-Spiele in der Vorrunde die Karten hatte, da war ich heiß und habe ich gesagt, okay, jetzt ist der Moment. Jetzt möchte ich es gerne durchziehen. Jetzt möchte ich so viele Spiele wie möglich, 22 Spieltage, 23 Spiele. Das ist mein großes Ziel. Und mit ein bisschen tauschen, mit ein bisschen Resale-Verkaufsphasen-Glück, wo man dann in irgendwelchen Warteschlangen hängt und hofft, dass man irgendwie möglichst früh durchkommt, hat sich dann tatsächlich auch so gestaltet, dass ich zum Beginn des Turniers für jeden Spieltag mindestens einmal Karten hatte. Am Ende musste ich noch mal nachjustieren, weil Deutschland ins Viertelfinale in Schüttler gekommen ist, aber das ist eine andere Geschichte. Da haben wir dann morgens früh um acht im Hotelzimmer noch die Karten geschossen. Aber ansonsten, bevor das Turnier losging, war klar, ich kann theoretisch zu 23 Spielen hingehen, wenn ich nicht gerade spontan krank werde.
Okay, und bei uns Journalistinnen und Journalisten war es so, wir mussten also alle unsere Daten eingeben, natürlich Pass und so weiter und so fort. Wir mussten allen LKA der Stadion, in denen wir sein wollten, mussten wir gewähren, dass sie uns durchsuchen und durchpflügen. Und das hat ja bei mir anscheinend auch besonders lange gedauert. Wie war das denn als in Anführungszeichen normaler Fan?
Einfacher, tatsächlich. Also wir haben ja gelernt jetzt im Laufe des Turniers, dass die Daten über diese App durchaus geteilt wurden, wo ich mich gerade aufhalte, wo ich mich in Nähe des Stadions befinde.
Die wissen jetzt, wo unsere Lokalität ist, in der wir uns treffen, Tobi, vor Spielen.
Wenn sie es wirklich runterbrechen auf uns beide und mein Kumpel, mit dem ich viel gemacht habe, schöne Grüße an dieser Stelle, dann könnten sie herausfinden, was der geheime Spot in München ist. Definitiv. Also jetzt mal unabhängig von der Geschichte, über die man sicherlich einzeln auch noch mal sprechen könnte, aber ist es so, wenn am Ende Familienmitglied eins Karten zugeteilt kriegt, Karten kauft und der Meinung ist, dass Familienmitglied eins da nicht hingehen möchte, dann kann Familienmitglied eins mir das Ganze über die Ticket-App die Tickets rüber schicken. Das ist komplikationslos möglich. Das geht wirklich innerhalb von Sekunden. Du kannst es dir vorstellen, dass ich bei so vielen Spielen öfter mal Tickets hin und her geschickt habe. Ich habe viele Leute mitgenommen ins Stadion. Ich war ja nicht immer nur alleine, sondern habe viele Begleiter mit gehabt. Ich habe Karten hin und her geschickt. Das ist wirklich. Ich drücke hier auf den Knopf und in dem Moment vibriert dein Handy und sagt, der Tobi hat dir gerade ein Ticket geschickt und dann kannst du das in deine App rüberführen. Das hat wirklich 1A reibungslos geklappt. Die haben dann auch keine Überprüfung mehr gemacht. Also wenn du jetzt hier LKA, BKA und wer auch immer. Wenn mein Vater mir das Ticket gekauft hat und gesagt hat, Tobi, ich kann nicht, geh du mal bitte hin. Hier ist die Karte. Dann war das halt meine. Ich stand offensichtlich nicht auf irgendeiner roten Liste. Ich weiß nicht, ob es irgendwas gab, wo man dann vielleicht nicht hinschicken konnte.
Aber jetzt wirst du ja auch so wie die anderen ja sicher aus. Du wirst ja auch die Kartenkäufer, die I Need Ticket Männer vor den Stadien gesehen haben, nie in Fällenkleidung, nie auch nur ansatzweise Fußball interessiert. Und man kannte manche der Gesichter auch aus der Bundesliga. Warum hat denn das funktioniert bei diesem Turnier? Wenn man ja eigentlich sehen können müsste, also Uefa, Moment mal, da bekommt jemand immer Tickets, eine Stunde vor Spielbeginn und später wandern sie wieder in ein anderes Wallet.
Also habe ich die Jungs, es ist jetzt tatsächlich, das ist jetzt ein Feld aus, es sind Jungs, habe ich schon in Hannover am Hauptbahnhof gesehen vor dem Öffnungsspiel. Die standen in Hannover am Hauptbahnhof. Ich war auf dem Weg nach München zu dir und sie standen hier schon mit I Need Ticket. Irgendwann wurde dann I Need Ticket for myself draus, also nicht in Hannover, aber in der Nähe des Stadions. Ja, natürlich brauchst du die für dich selbst. Also meine persönliche Meinung, ohne dass ich es jetzt bei der Uefa hinterfragt hätte, ist doch der Uefa scheißegal. Also was spielt das für die Uefa für eine Rolle? Die haben ihr Ticket, das haben sie verkauft und wenn das jetzt, ich sage mal, da wollen vier Schotten zum Eröffnungsspiel und einer wird krank, dann haben sie halt vier Tickets für drei Leute und dann wollen sie das loswerden und dann verkaufen sie das an jemanden, vielleicht auch unbedarfter als es besser wäre. Also man kann natürlich darüber nachdenken, ob man das nicht jemanden gibt, der ein ernsthaftes Interesse hat, dann auch selber ins Stadion zu gehen. Aber wenn da halt einer steht, eine Ticket, die Leute verkaufen es denen. Und wenn du sagst, dass da Accounts sind, die dann immer wieder ein, zwei, drei Stunden vor Spielbeginn viele Tickets kriegen und weiterleiten, glaubst du, wir haben nur ein Ticket? Glaubst du das wirklich? Nur ein Account? Also die werden doch rotieren. Also Login, Logout, das dürfte nicht schwierig sein. Ich gehe auch davon aus, wir haben mehrere Devices mit dabei. Und es gibt zumindest Berichte darüber, dass ein regelmäßiges Abmelden und Anmelden mit verschiedenen Accounts auf einem Gerät irgendwann zu einer Sperre führt. Also aber nicht bei drei, vier oder fünf Accounts auf einem Gerät. Irgendwann ist Schluss, aber ganz ehrlich, da wird doch der Tickl-Handel, der wird sich doch da was gedacht haben. Das werden wir schon hinbekommen.
Fair enough. Und stimmt ja, die haben wahrscheinlich nicht nur ein Device mit dabei. Aber dann wird mich mal der Eindruck von euch allen dreien interessieren. War es denn wirklich so ausverkauft, wie es uns immer verkauft wurde? Also Tobi grinst jetzt schon. Ich meine, du hast ja noch im Last-Minute die Tickets geholt. Aber ich überlege gerade, bei welchem Spiel das war. Es verschwimmt alles. Es war bei Spanien gegen Frankreich. Genau, es stimmt, die Spanienspieler. Da gab es ja immer Probleme, das Ticket-Contigent loszuwerden bis hin zum Finale. Also da habe ich einige Reseller, nenne ich sie jetzt mal, gesehen. Die waren fast schon verzweifelt, weil sie die Dinge nicht losgeworden sind. Habt ihr die Erfahrung auch gemacht vor den Stadien?
Ich gräte einfach kurz rein, übrigens mit den Tickets vor Ort zu Ende. Mein Last-Minute-Kauf war über den DFB ganz normal, fürs Deutschland-Spanien-Spiel in Stuttgart. Da gab es dann noch welche. Es gab hinterher dann wohl auch noch über die Spanier Karten. Ich hatte das Gefühl, ab K.O.-Runde hat man mehr Platz im Stadion. Vielleicht mag es Zufall gewesen sein. Wir haben Deutschland-Denemark, das war ausverkauft. Da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, Deutschland-Denemark, das war ausverkauft, in Dortmund. Aber dann England gegen Slowakei, Frankreich gegen Belgien, die beiden Spiele in Gelsenkirchen bzw. in Düsseldorf im Achtelfinale. Das mag Zufall sein, aber ich glaube, das konnte man in mehreren Blöcken sehen. Für unsere beiden Plätze hatten wir vier, fünf Plätze um uns herum Platz. Also es waren Lücken da. Klar kann sein, dass die Leute irgendwie runtergegangen sind zu den Fans-first-Bereichen, um zu supporten oder Stimmung zu machen. Aber ich glaube einfach, diese Spiele waren nicht ausverkauft. Es sind nicht alle Karten weggegangen.
Bei Georgia gegen Spanien war das in Köln zum Beispiel auch so ein Spiel, wo es große Lücken gab. Wie gesagt, es kann sein, dass die alle in den Stimmungsbereich gegangen sind. Ich weiß nicht, Matthias, was war dein Undruck aus den Stadien heraus?
Ja, so ähnlich eigentlich. Es gab hier und da immer mal wieder Lücken, aber das war schon eine relativ hohe Zahl. Also ich kann es nicht an der Prozentszahl festmachen, aber sie waren schon sehr, sehr gut gefüllt, die Stadien. Aber dass es nicht bis zum letzten Platz ausverkauft war, das hat man, glaube ich, bei fast jedem Spiel gesehen. Ich hatte ja eher so ein bisschen Einblick auf die Presse-Tribüne. Da hatte ich auch schon gedacht, da wird es Spiele geben, wo man echt Schwierigkeiten hat. Kleine Beobachtung vom Eröffnungsspiel. Da waren locker 10, 12 Schreibtische alleine in dem Block, wo ich war, frei. Das ganze Spiel über. Von daher, ich weiß nicht, ob die nicht abgerufen wurden oder ob da jemand einfach nur sich für ein Spiel gemeldet hat, wo er nicht hingefahren ist. Da hat die Uefa ja so eine schwarze Liste irgendwie versucht einzuführen. Würde mich auch mal interessieren, was daraus geworden ist. Weil es hieß ja, wer einmal seine Bestellung macht und dann nicht abruft, kriegt eine gelbe Karte und beim zweiten Mal kommt auf die schwarze Liste für Uefa-Veranstaltungen.
Und der Arbeitgeber wird angeschrieben, dass er noch nicht gekommen ist, es wird gepetzt.
Die No-Show-Rate irgendwie möglichst klein zu halten auf der Presse-Tribüne. Aber wie gesagt, ich war in allen zehn Stadien. Ich habe da schon viele Reihen leer gesehen und viele Tische, die leer waren. Also vielleicht waren es auch einfach nicht so viele Bestellungen bei manchen Spielen.
Ja, wobei, Joel, da hast du ja einen ganz guten Einblick. Und du kannst es auch vergleichen mit dem FC Bayern. Waren das vielleicht die Reihen? Es gab so für die Broadcaster auch Plätze, die frei waren, wenn jemand von diesem Team vor Ort war, der dann auf die Presse-Tribüne wollte und nicht was anderes zu tun hatte. Kommen daher diese Lücken, weil gerade beim Eröffnungsspiel ist ja wirklich seltsam, dass da noch rauskommt.
Die muss man ja auch bestellen, diese Karten. Also das waren die Karten, die ich immer gekriegt habe. Ich bin als Radiomensch auch unter den Broadcastern und komme dann auf diese Observer-Plätze. Und da hat die ARD, glaube ich, immer sechs oder sieben oder acht oder so für ein Spiel bekommen. Und dann konnte ich mich dann ARD intern drauf bewerben, sozusagen.
Genau, also wir hatten, glaube ich, in München 185 Plätze an diesen Tischen. Davon waren, glaube ich, die Mehrheit unten im Unteragel der Tribüne und dann eben ganz oben noch hier für die schreibende Zunft. Ich hatte das Gefühl, bei der Öffnungsspieltag war ich tatsächlich auch auf der Presset-Tribüne, dass es da Bereiche gab, die waren extrem voll. Gerade so auf Höhe der Mittellinie, logischerweise, und dann so in den ausufernden Rand, da musste ich tatsächlich auch Leute wegschicken, da war kein Platz mehr. In anderen Bereichen anscheinend war dann mehr Platz. Wenn ich das gewusst hätte, hätte ich dann mehr Leute unterbringen können. Ich hatte hier Leute, die auch vom Öffentlich-Rechtlichen angemeldet waren, die auf der Treppe standen, was tatsächlich ein Problem war.
Aber wie ist denn das überhaupt möglich? Denn jetzt hat ja die Uefa dieses Pick-your-Position-Tool eingeführt. Also sprich, man musste seinen Sitzplatz sich raussuchen. Da gab es dann Slots für die verschiedenen Medienvertreter. Priorität A, B, C, D, E. Die hatten jeweils eine Stunde Zeit, sich zu bewerben. Und wenn man es verpasst hat, dann wurde man von der Uefa irgendwo auf die stille Treppe geschickt. Ist mir tatsächlich bei einem Spiel passiert. Da war ich gerade auf der Autobahn und habe vergessen, rauszufahren, um meinen Tisch zu picken. Aber wie ist denn das dann möglich, dass dann manche stehen müssen?
Ich glaube, es liegt vor allem daran, und das hat Matthias ja vorhin gesagt, dass man auch in Stadion reinkommt mit seiner Akkreditierung, ohne dann tatsächlich einen Platz zu haben. Und mit Zugang in die Medien-Tribüne, also das waren die Zahlen 6 und 7, kamst du hier auf die Tribüne, kamst in Stadion rein. Und selbst wenn du jetzt dieses Spiel nicht gebucht hattest, aber vor Ort warst, bist du einfach im Stadion gewesen und hast den Zutritt zu dieser Tribüne verschafft.
Wobei, ich weiß nicht, wie deine Beobachtung war, das war in den Stadion auch ein bisschen unterschiedlich. Also es gab Stadien, wo die sehr, sehr genau darauf geguckt haben, beim Betreten des Blocks, ob man diese SAD, diese Extra-Karte für die Tribüne hatte. In München, würde ich sagen, war das eher nicht so wirklich der Fall.
Lass da mal gerne drüber sprechen, über die unterschiedlichen Situationen vor Ort, Joel. Du hast dann logischerweise immer nur die Münchner Perspektive. Aber lass mal zum Beispiel mit den Einlasskontrollen beginnen. Anekdotische Evidenz meinerseits. Eröffnungsspieltag, wir sind vor Stadionöffnung da und entscheiden uns dann, okay, wir wollen jetzt auch vor der Stadionöffnung rein, weil dann sind hier gerade 3000 Shots losgelassen und auch sehr viele Deutschland-Fans. Und wir kamen rein und ich wollte zum Beispiel meinen Rucksack durchsuchen lassen. Dann haben die gesagt, nee, nee, brauchen wir gar nicht. Da habe ich gefragt, gibt es hier ein Band, so wie sonst immer? Nee, nee, machen wir nicht. Dann kamen wir runter, da wurde dann gerade ein Flughafenscanner aufgebaut. Da dachte ich mir noch, ist das jetzt nicht das, muss ich jetzt warten, bis die aufgebaut sind? Haben sie mich vorbei geschickt. Dann schlicht sich ein YouTuber bei diesem Spiel als Maskottchen ins Stadion und beim nächsten Spiel wurde ich aber gleich dreimal kontrolliert, inklusive zweimal abtasten und da waren die Säse genau drauf. Und ich muss aber auch sagen, es war höchst unterschiedlich, was die Stadion angeht. Kann auch gerne noch mehr dazu sagen. Joel, willst du was zu diesem YouTuber-Vorfall erzählen? Was kannst du uns berichten? Sind da Wasserflaschen geflogen? Also natürlich nur diese Plastikflaschen, die es überall gab hinter den Kulissen.
Ja, witzigerweise ist das ja etwas, das passiert ist am Öffnungsspieltag, dass ich überhaupt nicht mitbekommen habe. Und war dann dort auf der Presse-Tribüne und im Volunteer-Center und habe nichts mitbekommen. Habe das tatsächlich erst zum nächsten Spieltag gehört. Ja, da ist einiges schiefgelaufen, offensichtlich. Das hatte auch Konsequenzen. Man muss dazu sagen, dass die Zugangskontrollen werden von privaten Sicherheitsdiensten gemacht. Das sind also keine Volunteers, die das machen, sondern das sind private Sicherheitsdienste. Davon gab es in München, glaube ich, zwei Dutzend, die Leute gestellt haben. Also immer irgendwie verschiedene Teams, hunderte Leute. Und die Qualität der Leute, die dort arbeiten, ist unterschiedlich, um es mal ganz vorsichtig zu sagen. Klar, relativ wenig qualifizierte Leute, Leute, die sowas nie machen, die gegebenenfalls auch der deutsche Sprache nicht unbedingt mächtig sind und die an Orten hingestellt werden, wo es auch nicht wirklich Spaß macht. Jetzt kam dort eins zum anderen und die hatten das wirklich sehr gut gemacht, habe ich dann im Nachhinein gesehen. Aber die Ordner hatten dann unterschiedliche Leibchen. Gelb war das normale Fußvolk und Orange waren dann diese Abschnittsleiter. Und der Abschnittsleiter, der dort war, der hatte offensichtlich auch keine Ahnung von dem, was er da machen sollte und hat ihn dann durchgewunken. Und das hatte dann auch Konsequenzen.
Also Marvin Wildhage war das natürlich. Ich werde das Video in den Show Notes verlinken, wenn ihr es nicht gesehen habt. Es war besonders schwierig, denn sie hatten sich Parkausweise gefälscht und so weiter. Also sprich, das war jetzt auch nochmal mehr, als einfach nur in den Stadion reinlaufen. Das muss man auch zur Verteidigung der Leute sagen. Plus Eröffnungsspieltag. Ich habe es vor Ort gesehen. Wie gesagt, dieser Scanner war noch gar nicht aufgebaut. Beim nächsten Spieltag stand er dann. Es schien alles sehr auf Kante genäht gewesen zu sein. Aber ich habe Tobi sehr deutlich und nachdrücklich nicken sehen. Als du gesagt hast, es gab unterschiedliche Qualität bei der Abtastrate, würde ich es jetzt mal nennen.
Erstmal danke an Marvin Wildhage und für die vielen, vielen Likes, die mein Tweet zu seinem Verhalten im Stadion gebracht hat. Herrlicher Auftakt damals gewesen. Ja, ich bin, weiß ich nicht so, bei 60, 50, 40 Spielen pro Saison im Stadion. Und die meisten sind dann schon irgendwie Richtung Profi-Fußballer, erste, zweite, dritte Liga und dementsprechend dann auch mit Sicherheitspersonal, die dich abtasten. Aber, boah, ganz ehrlich, bei der Euro, das war noch lower, als es im Bundesliga- oder Zweitliga-Betrieb stattfindet. Das war nichts. Also ja, das war relativ klar vorgeklärt. Taschen, DIN A4 Größe. Ich habe Leute gesehen, die hatten Rucksäcke dabei, da konnte man im negativen Sinne halbe Sprengsätze mit reinbringen. Im positiven Sinne hätte man dann zelten können oder so im Stadion. So groß waren die Rucksäcke. Und was mein persönliches Erleben angeht, ich glaube von 21 mal, wenn es hochkommt, zweimal, bin ich so kontrolliert worden, dass ich gesagt habe, okay, der hat sich wirklich dafür interessiert, was ich heute dabei habe und was ich mit reinbringe. Und dem Rest war es in Anführungsstrichen wirklich scheißegal.
Matthias, wie ging es dir?
Ich kann deine anekdotische Evidenz bestätigen in München. Beim ersten Mal habe ich mir auch gedacht, wieso muss ich denn jetzt gar nicht durch dieses Zelt mit dem Scanner, wieso kann ich denn trotz meinem Rucksack einfach so vorbeigehen? Und dann zum Halbfinale war ich nochmal da. Und da bin ich tatsächlich auch mehrfach abgetastet worden und mehrfach wurde mein Rucksack angeguckt. Ja, also diese Unterschiede habe ich auch festgestellt. Ich hatte meistens das gleiche Besteck bei mir. Meistens ein Rucksack und sonst nicht viel dabei, mit einer Ausnahme, wo ich mit Koffer unterwegs war. Das war aber immer relativ problemlos. Vielleicht eher so der Vergleich zu anderen Turnieren. Ich habe bei jedem Turnier bisher, vor allen Dingen bei Weltmeisterschaften, aber bei jedem Turnier bisher Stress gehabt bei der Einlasskontrolle zum Stadion. Mindestens einmal pro Turnier, weil ich so ein Mikrofon dabei habe für Interviews. Also das sieht aus wie ein handelsübliches Mikrofon. Das ist aber eigentlich nur ein Aufnahmegerät. Damit kann ich nicht senden oder irgendwas. Ich kann einfach nur aufnehmen. Das ist ein MP3-Rekorder. Hat aber so einen schönen Plop-Schutz mit in den Farben meines Senders. Und da haben bei jedem Turnier die Ordner oder die Sicherheitskräfte gedacht, das wäre etwas, was ich benutze, um irgendwie in die Welt zu senden. Und haben sich beschwert, dass der Aufkleber auf Funkfrequenz getestet oder irgendwas drauf fehlt. Und dann musste ich sowohl in Russland als auch in Katar bei mindestens einem Stadion jeweils immer in das Zelt und die Probleme klären, mit irgendjemandem, der zumindest leidlich Englisch sprach. Und das hat meistens immer so eine halbe Stunde bis Stunde gedauert, bis man schließlich reindurfte, bis sie verstanden haben, dass es zum Aufnehmen ist und nicht zum Senden. Und das war hier total... Ich habe immer darauf gewartet, dass jetzt in irgendeinem Stadion mal einer sagt, mach mal die Tasche auf und zeig mir mal dein Mikro. Passt und weiter. Angeblich, ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch war, also Flaschen durfte man als Fan natürlich nicht mit reinnehmen. Im Pressebereich irgendwie stand, glaube ich, auch drauf, durfte man nicht. Ich habe regelmäßig mindestens eine 1-Liter-Flasche bei mir getragen, hat auch nie jemanden gestört. Hat übrigens aber, damit schließe ich die Geschichten von früheren Turnieren ab, in Qatar auch niemanden gestört. Nur, wenn der falsche Sponsor drauf war, dann musste man den kurz abreißen und also das Etikett abmachen und durfte die Flasche trotzdem mitnehmen. Auch das war jetzt kein Problem.
Ja, bei den Sponsoren sind sie nämlich dann ganz genau. Also ich bin noch so hin und hergerissen, wie ich das jetzt bewerten will. Weil auf der einen Seite ist es natürlich ein Sicherheitsrisiko, wenn nicht ordentlich kontrolliert wird. Auf der anderen Seite halte ich allerdings auch viele Sicherheitsmaßnahmen für etwas überzogen im Rahmen von Großveranstaltungen, die mit Fußball zu tun haben. Weil ja eben dann doch, und da kann ja ein Beweis dafür sein, dann doch eher wenig passiert. Aber bei Sponsoren, da waren sie ganz genau. Ich habe unter anderem in Frankfurt Ordner beobachtet. Das sind dann eben keine Volunteers. Die Volunteers, Joel, die hatten ja glaube ich alle die gesponserten Schuhe, alle die gesponserte Kleidung bis hin zur Socke. Ich habe einmal eingesehen, da hatte nicht die richtigen Socken an. Da dachte ich mir gleich, die Socken waren nicht gesponsert, Joel?
Wir sollten keine Socken eines anderen Herstellers tragen.
Aber das ist ja interessant, weil es hatten wirklich viele, hatten diese weißen Socken mit dann eben vom Sportartikel-Hersteller mit den grünen Streifen, die so perfekt zur Jacke usw. gepasst haben. Dann waren die gar nicht dabei. Okay, und dann sind wir aber nämlich schon bei den anderen Marken. Denn ich habe Ordner gesehen in Frankfurt. Die mussten als allererstes, da war ich eben auch wieder sehr früh im Stadion, als allererstes mussten alle, die die falsche Schuhmarke anhatten, nämlich eine andere als von Adidas, die mussten mit schwarzen Tape ihre Logos überkleben. Hast du sowas auch beobachtet in München? Das finde ich dann nämlich schon, also das finde ich halt interessant, dass man auf der einen Seite so genau sein kann und auf der anderen Seite dann wieder so lax sein kann. Und die Sicherheitsmaßnahmen, sie waren sehr unterschiedlich. Also am schnellsten und am professionellsten ging es in Frankfurt, da war ich, glaube ich, dreimal. Da habe ich dann auch gefragt, als ich dann am letzten Tag da war, das war auch das letzte Spiel in Frankfurt, müsste Portugal gewesen sein, habe ich dann auch gefragt, sag mal, wer von euch hier arbeitet am Flughafen? Weil das ist so, und dann gingen gleich drei Hände hoch, nicht so, okay, alles klar, jetzt verstehe ich, warum es hier immer so schnell geht, warum ihr so genau seid, warum ihr Vorder- und Rückseite abscannet. Die waren sehr, sehr genau. Bei anderen, ich bin einmal durch den VIP-Eingang, andere Geschichte, ich war ganz normal akkreditiert, keine Sorge. Aber das war ganz interessant, da musste man noch durch einen Strahlenschutz-Sensor durchfahren mit dem Fahrzeug, wurde kurz darauf geprüft. Ansonsten war es relativ lax, sage ich mal. Und aber bei den Sponsoren, dass man da dann so einen Aufstand macht? Nun ja, aber so ganz wundert es einen ja auch nicht. Habt ihr noch irgendwas zu diesem Thema? Oder wollen wir vielleicht mal bei so schönen Dingen bleiben, wie die Stimmung und so weiter war und die Organisation?
Ich würde gerne noch mal kurz zu dieser Einlassgeschichte an sich kommen. Zwei Punkte. Also das eine, was ich bis heute nicht verstanden habe, aber vielleicht liegt es auch wirklich an mir, ist dieses Vorabaktivieren des Tickets. Also das werdet ihr als Journalisten wahrscheinlich nicht gehabt haben. Ihr werdet wahrscheinlich dahingegangen sein mit eurer Akkreditierung, und gesagt, hi, hier bin ich. Ich musste mein Ticket vorabaktivieren. Das heißt, du gehst durch die erste Sicherheitskontrolle, was so ein äußerer Ring ist, und da stehen einfach unendlich Volunteers, die dieses Ticket aktivieren. Dann leuchtet dein Handy grün, da steht dann drauf One Ticket Activated, oder halt auch 2, 3, 4, 5, weil du kannst ja theoretisch auch deine ganze Familie mitnehmen, auf deinem Handy, weil Opa hat kein Handy, das Kind hat noch kein Handy, oder wie auch immer. Dann kommst du zur nächsten Kontrolle, da wirst du dann mehr oder weniger abgetastet, also meistens halt weniger. Gehst dann noch einen Schritt und kommst dann durch die Einlasskontrolle, wo du das Ticket wirklich scannst am Scanner und gehst dann durchs Drehkreuz durch. Dieser Punkt, diese erste Aktivierung, hat sich nach 21 Versuchen bei mir nicht erschlossen. Ihr werdet es wahrscheinlich auch nicht wissen, weil ihr es nicht gemacht habt. Oder Joel, vielleicht hast du irgendwie auch nicht. Okay, es hat das Ganze so ein bisschen entzerrt, hatte ich das Gefühl. Aber warum das jetzt notwendig war und warum ich... Also man hat natürlich damit die Leute an der ersten Kontrolle aussortiert, die kein gültiges Ticket hatten. Aber das kannst du halt auch per Sichtkontrolle machen. Oder du lässt die Leute halt durch und sie scheitern, dann spätestens an der zweiten Kontrolle ist. Ich weiß es nicht, was das für ein tieferer Sinn von Uefa gewesen ist.
Ich habe eine Vermutung, aber es wird wahrscheinlich eine Vermutung bleiben. Aber erinnern wir uns ans letzte Männer-EM-Finale mit dem Sturm aufs Wembley-Stadion, wo eben ganz viele Menschen ohne Tickets versucht haben, reinzukommen. Und es ja auch einige geschafft haben. Da gab es ja danach die parlamentarische Untersuchung, die auch herausgefunden hat, es war reines Glück, dass hier niemand ums Leben gekommen ist, weil es ja massenpaarenartige Zustände waren. Wahrscheinlich würde ich sagen, ging es darum, dass irgendwie gewährleistet sein muss, noch vor den eigentlichen Kontrollen, wo es so eng wird, haben wir einen Bereich, wo schon die Ticketkontrolle stattfindet. Dass es dann mit Scannen und so weiter ist, das ist wahrscheinlich dann einfach so, wollten sie haben, weil sie auch ihre App dafür ja auch programmiert haben. Aber ich weiß nicht, Matthias, wie du das siehst, du warst ja noch bei viel mehr Turnieren, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das eine Lehre daraus ist, weil das waren ja wirklich harte und schlimme Zustände.
Ja, das ist auch die einzige Erklärung, die ich habe. Ich habe tatsächlich bei einem Spiel auch Karten im Fanblock gehabt und habe es auch einmal mitgemacht, dieses Spiel, wo dann auch diese Schilder stehen, Activate your Bluetooth und so, habe ich auch drüber nachgedacht, aber mir dann relativ schnell einfach weitere Gedanken verboten, weil ich keine Lust hatte mehr drüber nachzudenken. Aber tatsächlich ist es die einzige Erklärung, die ich auch habe. Also, dass man versucht irgendwie, jetzt auch unter der Folie dessen, was wir beim Copa-America-Finale gesehen haben, mit Leuten, die irgendwie durch Heizungsschächte oder irgendwas ins Stadion rein klettern, dass man das irgendwie versucht hat, auf jeden Fall zu verhindern, je nachdem, wie brisant da die Paarungen auch sind, die da aufeinandertreffen. Sonst fällt mir auch nichts ein.
Ja, also solche Überlegungen haben wir uns natürlich in die Richtung auch gemacht. Es gab es auch schon vor acht Jahren. 2016 gab es auch schon so einen äußeren Ring. Da wurde das Handy dann nicht aktiviert, sondern man hat das Sicht geprüft, ob die Menschen ein Ticket haben, ob sie über diesen äußeren Ring hinaus Richtung Stadion gehen können. Ich weiß es nicht. Kann natürlich sein, dass dieses Champions League-Finale da einen Unterschied gemacht hat. Andererseits der äußere Ring, das ist der, den ich wirklich mit, ich sag mal, 20, 30 gewaltbereiten Vögeln relativ leicht überlaufen kann. Der zweite Teil, wo dann die Gitter sind und die Drehkreuze, da wird es dann in der Regel bei den Stadien schwieriger. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Egal. Das war jetzt die Geschichte. Irgendetwas wird der Uefa daran wichtig gewesen sein.
Oder wäre Bluetooth wichtig zum Stichwort Daten sammeln, dass man wirklich weiß, wo unterwegs ist?
Also die Push-Nachricht, aktivieren sie bitte der Bluetooth. Dürfte ich öfter gekriegt haben als eine Tor in irgendwo Push-Nachricht von der Europameisterschaft. Das bin ich mir ziemlich sicher. Und was ich noch ganz kurz zum Abschluss zu diesem Thema einlassen wollte, was ein riesengroßer Unterschied ist zwischen Bundesliga, Zweite Liga, manchmal auch DFB-Pokalbetrieb und dieser Europameisterschaft, sind die Zeiten. Die Zeiten, wo die Leute in Stadien gehen. Wenn du bei der Euro eine Stunde vor Spielbeginn in Stadien gekommen bist, hast du das Gefühl gehabt, es sind schon 95 Prozent der Leute drin. Die Straßenbahnen raus, also die meisten Stadien, Düsseldorf, Gelsenkirchen, München, ihr kennt es selber, sind ja so, dass man auf einen Punkt hinausfährt. Das heißt, die Straßenbahnen dorthin sind in der Regel nicht mehr knallvoll, meistens sogar leer. Also ich bin nach Düsseldorf vom Hauptbahnhof bzw. von der Altstadt zum Stadion 55 Minuten vor Spielbeginn gefahren und die Straßenbahn war leer, weil alle Leute schon im Stadion waren. Das ist genau entgegengesetzt zu dem, was man in der Bundesliga erfährt. Die Leute sind routiniert, die Leute wissen, wie sie zu ihrem Platz kommen. Es ist halt eins von 17 Heimspielen, es ist Routine. Man geht vielleicht schon das 20. Jahr zu seinem Verein. Da reicht es ja auch, wenn ich 10 Minuten vorher komme. Bei der Europameisterschaft sind die Leute einfach heiß, die wollen früh entscheiden. Das hat die Sache, zumindest wenn man das wusste und wenn man auch selber gar nicht so heiß darauf war, so wie wir, unbedingt zwei Stunden vor Spielbeginn im Stadion zu sein. Warum? Also es passiert ja nicht so aufsiedbar.
Hallo, da hat ein DJ aufgelegt und das war nur fast immer die gleichen Lieder.
Der DJ war aber auch nur an manchen Orten. Der war auch nicht jedes Mal mit dabei. Der musste, glaube ich, auch überraschenderweise sich nicht dreiteilen. Also das war für die Leute, die entspannt zum Stadion gerne kommen wollen, war das ein riesengroßer Vorteil im Vergleich zum zum Beispiel Bundesliga-Betrieb, wo du einfach sagst, wir haben noch 45 Minuten Zeit, jetzt kommen wir in 20 Minuten am Stadion an. Wichtig war, 20.48 Uhr oder 17.48 Uhr oder 14.48 Uhr, wenn dann die Pre-Show losging, das ist der Moment, wenn man da am Platz saß, war alles Tutti Frutti.
Weil die wolltest du nicht verpassen, die Pre-Show, die überall gleich war, bei jedem einzelnen Spiel.
Ich wusste, dass wir beide heute in diese Diskussion kommen und ich bin kein Freund von der Öffnungsspiele und vom Finale. Das hätte man sich beides wirklich hochgradig haken können. Das ist ja Quatsch, diese ganzen Shows da. Aber ich fand, diese zwölf Minuten vor dem Spiel, ja, es war immer das Gleiche und ja, ich habe es 21 Mal mir angucken müssen. Aber es gibt genug Leute, die das genau einmal gesehen haben. Ich fand, es war nicht schlecht gemacht. Es war so reduziert mit diesen Fähnchen und so weiter. Da kamen ein paar Leute aufs Spielfeld gelaufen. Ich meine, ihr habt es alle gesehen. Dann haben sie die teilnehmenden Fahnen da hochgehalten und ein bisschen geschwenkt. Und dann kam dieses typische Lied. Ich weiß nicht, wie die heißen, aber das kam dann halt auch jedes Mal. Und danach kam die Mannschaft, dann kamen die Hymnen. Es war so ein Kliemanns, der nach oben ging. Es war perfekt für, es ist jetzt 21 Uhr, jetzt kann es losgehen. Ich finde, das war so reduziert und nicht übertrieben, dass ich es 21 Mal nicht als störend empfunden habe. Im Gegensatz zum Eröffnungsspiel und Finale, wo es dann dieser Quatsch war. Naja, da brauchen wir nicht drüber zu reden.
Ja, ich verstehe, was du meinst. Und so störend war es auch nicht. Was mich am meisten gestört hat, war, ich habe jetzt diese Melodie wieder im Ohr. Ich auch, gerade hinten. Weil bei 200 Dezibel, Joel auch, glaube ich, es würde einfach bei 200 Dezibel reingebraten. Und ich habe nachts wirklich, ich habe davon geträumt. Ich hatte Träume, wo quasi dieses Lied lief. Und ich weiß nicht, wie ich das finde. Ja, ich weiß, du hast recht, es ist nicht schlimm. Ich fand, ehrlich gesagt, auch die Eröffnungsfeiern jetzt Voröffnungsspiel und Finale, sie waren angenehm kurz. Und mein Gott, die Finaleöffnungsfeier hatte das Thema Händeschütteln. Ich meine, das ist doch, also nach Corona, was könnte es für ein schöneres Moment geben, zu sagen, es ist vorbei, Leute, egal wie hoch die Zahlen gerade sind. Aber was ich eher dann interessant fand, da bin ich ja dann so ein Sacker von, dass ich immer dann gucke, wie wird es im Fernsehen präsentiert. Denn das war das Interessante. Sie haben einen halbwegs guten Mix gefunden, dass diese Eröffnungszeremonie, dass die sowohl im Stadion funktioniert, als auch für das Fernsehen. Aber ich habe dann immer gleich einen Stream angeworfen und habe geguckt, wie die Kamerafahrten sind. Und das war halt wirklich in jedem Stadion gleich. Es war immer gleich, wann haben sie von oben das Stadion gezeigt, das war, wenn die Fahnen aufgerollt wurden, wann haben sie die Führungskamera gezeigt, wann wurde dann langsam ungeschwenkt. Ich bin dann irgendwann schon blind aufgestanden, weil ich wusste, jetzt kommen gleich die Teams und dann kommt ja gleich If You Are Able, Stand Up for the National Anthems und dann können wir endlich hier ein bisschen Niederländer beim Schunken zusehen usw. Dann war ich wieder voll mit dabei. Aber es war immer, immer gleich. Und da muss man aber auch dann die Durchführenden loben. Es gab ganz, ganz selten mal kleinere Fehler, weil nach so was habe ich dann halt immer geguckt. Also einmal ist ein Kind über die dänische Fahne ein bisschen gestolpert. Das sollte nicht sein. Einmal standen tatsächlich die Fahne der Slowakei, war es, glaube ich. Ich bin mir ganz sicher, dass die einen halben Meter zu weit links war, weil es war nicht semestrisch. Und eigentlich messen die das ja vorher aus mit diesen Bändern. Da kommt ja der Typ mit dem Headset, der also ähnlich sieht er aus wie ich und ist dann ganz beschäftigt und bringt dann alle an ihre Position. Aber ansonsten lief es sehr gut.
Ich habe immer darauf gewartet, dass man bei einer Eröffnungsfeier, ich habe es nicht gesehen, irgendein Buchstabe von dem Stadion in einer verkehrten Reihenfolge stand. Da habe ich die ganze Zeit darauf gewartet. Was ist nicht passiert tatsächlich?
Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt. Die waren irgendwie nummeriert, glaube ich. Also zum einen hatten natürlich die Fahnträger eine genaue Reihenfolge. Das hat man schon immer gesehen, wenn die an der Seite reingekommen sind. Das war immer identisch. Und ich glaube, die hatten das irgendwo so an der Stelle, wo sie es gehalten haben, stand das, glaube ich, auch drauf. Hatten die, glaube ich, Nummern. Joel, kannst du dieses Opening-Ceremony-Lied noch hören? Oder kannst du überhaupt irgendeins von diesen Liedern hören, was einem ja wirklich bei einer brutalen Lautstärke ins Hirn gebraten wurde?
Ich muss ja gestehen, dass sich diese Lieder in meinem Kopf sich alle vermischt haben. So oft, wie ich diese Playlist, die ja ständig abgespielt wurde, gehört habe. Das begann ja meistens, gerade für uns, wenn wir schon am Nachmittag im Stadion waren. Bei den Proben hörten wir das ja alles schon mal. Dann noch mal.
Ist dir bei den Proben was schiefgegangen, Joel? Gab es mal einen Regisseur, der völlig durchgedreht ist?
Nee, habe ich so nicht miterlebt. Ich glaube tatsächlich, wir hatten einmal, dass die Fahnen-Kids tatsächlich Seitenverkehrt reingelaufen sind und dann halt falsch standen. Aber gut, dafür ist die Probe ja da. Ansonsten habe ich nur mal gesehen, wie die Leute, die da das machten, hießen ja Ceremony Maker im Volontier-Jargon. Und dass da mal einer weggerutscht ist und die anderen das dann aufgefangen haben. Aber ansonsten lief es eigentlich gut. Ich muss aber wie Tobi sagen, es hat mir eigentlich auch ganz gut gefallen. Es war kurz genug und es machte halt auch jedes Stadion immer einzigartig. Dieses eine Bild mit den Fahnen und dem Ort und Euro, sodass wenn man dann, so wie ich, oft auf der Pressetribüne Höhe Mittellinie stand, jedes Foto, zumindest kannst du das Spiel unterscheiden. Ansonsten war ja alles gleich.
Und bitte einen großen Applaus für Didi, einen so großen Anteil zum Gelingen dieser Europamassenschaft. War doch immer der Spruch, der dann kam vorher.
Also meine Lieblingsanimation der ZuschauerInnen war bei Eröffnungs- und beim Finale, wo sie wirklich fast schon verzweifelt ihnen versucht haben, zu erklären, dass sie jetzt Teil der Opening Ceremony sind und dass sie bitte zu einem gewissen Zeitpunkt die, ich will es ja gar nicht Choreo, aber halt die Farbplättchen hochhalten sollen. Und wie fantastisch das war, dass das die Schotten nicht hingekriegt haben beim Eröffnungsspiel, weil sie dachten, bei der Probe, das wäre es jetzt schon gewesen, alle zusammengeknölt haben und schon runtergeworfen haben und später, als eigentlich der Moment kam, war dann die deutsche Fahne, die war wunderbar vollständig da und bei den Schotten nur noch so einzelne, die so verknitterte Dinger hochgehalten haben.
Aber ich glaube, es war ihnen auch scheißegal.
Ja, zu Recht natürlich auch.
Also es war ja wirklich, 20.48 sollten sie diese Dinger hochhalten, 20.44 hat man ihnen gesagt, ihr müsst um 20.48 diese Dinger hochhalten und alle hoch. Und 20.46 runtergeschmissen, Thema erledigt. Ah, das war super, das war ein super Auftakt, das ist komplett in die Hose gegangen.
Ja, es war was Besonderes. Wie steht ihr dem Thema gegenüber, der Countdown zum Anpfiff? Und habt ihr das auch erlebt? Ich habe ein Spiel erlebt, da hat der Schiedsrichter sich gedacht, nee, nee, nicht mit mir und hat einfach noch drei Sekunden länger gewartet, bis er gepfiffen hat. Fand ich sehr gut, weil ein Akt der Rebellion, wahrscheinlich hat er danach nie wieder gepfiffen. Ich hätte es mal vorher noch recherchieren müssen. Aber wie steht ihr zu diesem Thema? Es ist schon, bis zum Anpfiffen wird eventisiert. Ich will es jetzt gar nicht nur schlecht machen, es geht ja auch um Stimmung, aber es ist schon, weiß nicht.
Da kommt ja immer noch so ein Officer von der Uefa an den Rang, der auch noch zusätzlich zum Countdown die Zeichen gibt, so Hand hoch und Hand zur Seite. Und möglicherweise war der bei dem Spiel einfach drei Sekunden später dran, als die Leinwand, keine Ahnung, weil im Moment entscheidet, der ja wann gepfiffen wird. Ja, ich brauch es nicht. Tatsächlich habe ich es einmal gebraucht, weil ich ein Element für einen Radiobeitrag brauchte und das irgendwie ein schöner Einstieg war, zu sagen, es wird noch einmal Countdown in dieser Stadt gezählt und dann hört das hier auf. Aber ich brauch es nicht für das Stadion-Erlebnis, ehrlich gesagt, und ihr anderen wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Brauchen tue ich es auch nicht. Ich finde, man muss sich auf diese Euro dann auch schon so einlassen, dass man sagt, es ist was anderes als der reguläre Bundesliga-Zweitliga-Betrieb und dass es dann dazugehört, genauso wie dieses Pregame-Dingen mit den Fahnen. Wenn man sich darauf einlässt und sagt, das ist so, ich kann damit leben, dann finde ich, ist es völlig in Ordnung, so ein 10 zu 0-Counter zu machen. Ja, meinetwegen. Also gestern beim Finale, wir nehmen ja heute am Montag auf, es war irgendwie schon, also für mich war das auch so ein Moment, wo ich dachte, oh, scheiße, jetzt ist wirklich gleich alles vorbei. Jetzt startet das allerletzte Spiel. Und ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass das für viele Leute dann der Start auch überhaupt zu irgendeinem Spiel war und dementsprechend wichtig und gar nicht so schlecht, dass es einfach jemand mal kurz von 10 zu 0 runterzählt. Oder die meisten haben ja dann auch sogar laut mitgezählt. Ist schon okay. Komm, machen wir mit. Bitte nicht in die Bundesliga übernehmen, aber für so eine Euro.
Ja, vielleicht muss man auch aufpassen, dass man nicht so ein Zyniker wird, allein weil man es 15 Mal erlebt hat. Und das ist ja nicht die normale Position, also das stimmt natürlich auch. Aber weil ihr das vorhin, ich weiß gar nicht, du hast, glaube ich, das gesagt, die Horden an Volunteers, die überall standen. Jetzt haben wir gelernt, es sollen nur 1.600 pro Spielort gewesen sein. Ich kann das auch gar nicht glauben. Matthias, ist dir das auch so gegangen, dass du, also ich habe so viele Volunteers gesehen, alle waren nett, alle waren hilfsbereit, selbst wenn sie nicht wussten, wie sie mir helfen konnten, aber sie wollten. Das war wirklich was, was mir aufgefallen ist bei diesem Turnier, wie zahlreich einfach die Unterstützung war. Und für die Fans muss es ja ähnlich gewesen sein. Ist dir das auch aufgefallen?
Total, es ist mir sehr positiv in Erinnerung, alle hilfsbereit, immer versucht, eine Lösung zu finden, wenn es immer ein Problem gab, egal wie klein oder groß es war, dass es dann auch angenehm für alle war. Also wirklich absolut toll dieser Einsatz, ist ja auch von allen, glaube ich, gewürdigt worden. Also egal, mit wem man gesprochen hat, alle haben irgendwie sofort über die Volunteers geredet, dass das irgendwie so eine Sternstunde dieser EM auch war. Kann ich nur einstimmen, wenn das Lob, also das war eine tolle Geschichte. Lass mich noch eine Sache gerade zu diesem Erlebnis im Stadion sagen. Ich fand es übrigens relativ zurückgenommen, angenehm zurückgenommen gegenüber anderen Turnieren, auch was so in der Halbzeitpause passiert ist. Also hat man irgendwie dann so an diesem Tag vor x Jahren ist das und das Tor bei irgendeiner Europameisterschaft gefallen. Okay, oder jetzt lockt euch in die App ein und postet eure Bilder in die Fancam. Ja, meinetwegen, wer möchte, soll es halt machen, aber nicht so ein sehr aggressives jetzt kommt die Kisscam und das müssen alle mitmachen, so NBA-siert, wie das bei früheren Turnieren schon mal war. Das ist mir echt auch positiv in Erinnerung geblieben, das in die Klammer gesprochen und ansonsten großes Lup auf die Volunteers.
Und ich glaube, da möchte sich Tobi anschließen.
Bei beidem tatsächlich, sowohl bei der Halbzeitgeschichte, das war weniger als in der Bundesliga und in der zweiten Liga. Jetzt mal ganz ehrlich, das war reduzierter, es wurde nicht auf irgendwelche verkleinerten Tore geschossen, es gab keine 50.000 Euro zu gewinnen, du konntest kein Auto, Basketballkorb, was auch immer Geschichten erzählen. Das war wirklich gut und sie hatten meistens das in so eine Quiz-Form gepackt, keine Ahnung, wer hat 1988 bei der Europameisterschaft dies und das gemacht. Das war wirklich nett, das war, genau wie Matthias gesagt hat, reduziert. Und wenn es um die Volunteers geht, also ich hatte jetzt tatsächlich nicht so viel mit ihnen zu tun, also sie hatten sicherlich mit den Akkreditierungen deutlich mehr Kontakte gehabt, aber an dieser Stelle, ich kann es nicht lassen, die Düsseldorfer Volunteers zu grüßen. Ich war bei allen fünf Spielen in Düsseldorf und wer mir bei Instagram folgt, hat es wahrscheinlich gesehen, dass ich mich vor jedem Spiel, vor Stadion gestellt habe, in Instagram reingeblökt habe. Ich bin Tobi und das ist mein und dann habe ich durchgezählt erstes, zweites, drittes, viertes Spiel bei dieser Europameisterschaft und natürlich wird das irgendwann ein bisschen langweilig und dann bin ich bei meinem dritten Spiel in Düsseldorf, bin ich zu den Volunteers hingegangen beim Einlass und die da so auf diesen, gab es in München auch, auf diesen Schiedsrichterstühlen oder auf diesen Bademeisterstühlen oben saßen mit Megafon und dann die Leute, die regiert haben. Und es war schon relativ zeitnah zum Anpfiff und ich sage, kann einer vielleicht von euch irgendwie mal ganz kurz mit dem Megafon, willst du das Megafon haben? Ich sage, ja ich nehme es auch selber. Dann habe ich das Megafon genommen und habe meinen Spruch halt mit Megafon gemacht, mein Kumpel hat es gefilmt und dann habe ich beim vierten Spiel in Düsseldorf dachte ich mir, das versuchen wir wieder. Dann habe ich mich selber gefilmt und beim fünften Mal bin ich hingekommen und dann kam der eine schon zu mir und meinte, du bist doch der, der immer den Spruch, ich sage ja genau. Also es war wirklich, es war fantastisch. Dann hat der Typ, dem habe ich das Megafon in die Hand gegeben und der hat mir ins Gesicht gerührt, das ist Tobi und das ist sein, ich weiß nicht mehr, 15. Spiel oder so. Also die waren wirklich locker drauf, die hatten eine gute Zeit, die waren auf jeden Fall mega nett und total hilfsbereit, kooperationsbereit und deshalb beste Grüße an die Düsseldorfer Volunteers und an alle anderen, die überall ziemlich sicher einen sehr, sehr guten Job gemacht haben.
Joel, wie viele Volunteers?
Stellvertretend herzlichen Dank.
16.000 Volunteers müssten es ja dann gewesen sein, wenn es 1.600 pro Stadt waren. Joel, was habt ihr denn dafür bekommen letztlich und wie groß war der Aufwand? Also die Tage, was wir schon vorhin bemessen, aber das wird sich ja auch nochmal unterschieden haben von Volunteer zu Volunteer.
Also es gibt, wenn ich in meinem Bekanntenkreis oder so sage, ich habe bei der EM Volunteer gemacht, dann gibt es immer zwei Fragen, hast du Karten für die Spiele bekommen und wurdet ihr dafür bezahlt? Das sind die zwei Fragen, die ständig kommen. Die Antwort darauf ist Nein und Nein. Grundvoraussetzung für das Volunteer sein ist eigentlich bei jedem Turnier wird dir vorher gesagt, du bist Volunteer, du darfst nicht die Spiele im Stadion gucken und Geld gibt es keins, denn du bist freiwillig dabei. Jetzt kann man darüber diskutieren, dazu kommen wir wahrscheinlich noch, muss man das für so Mastodonten wie die Uefa, FIFA und Konsorten machen?
Gewinn bei dieser EM, 1,7 Milliarden Euro.
Genau, es ist da nicht ein bisschen Aufwandsentschädigung für ein paar Volunteers dabei. Es gibt ja jetzt in Paris zu den Olympischen Spielen gab es, ich möchte sie nicht Gewerkschaften nennen, aber Gruppierungen, die in diesem Sinne aktiv werden wollten, was der französische Staat natürlich nicht über sich hat ergehen lassen, aber ja, es ist tatsächlich ein fairer Punkt. Ich sage immer, ich mache das und das machen wahrscheinlich die meisten Volunteers, weil es mir Spaß macht, dabei zu sein. Es ist interessant, einen gewissen Einblick in das Funktionieren eines Turniers zu bekommen, den man sonst nicht hat. Das ist jetzt der offizielle Sprech, den ich immer verwende und da wir unter uns sind, kann ich es ja sagen, meine einzige Motivation bei dieser ganzen Geschichte ist, neben diesen Kleinigkeiten ist es natürlich, alle Spiele im Stadion zu sehen. Das habe ich bei jedem Turnier, bei dem ich bislang volontiert habe, geschafft. Also ich habe alle Spiele der WM 2006 hier in München gesehen, ich habe die Spiele der letzten EM hier in München alle gesehen und auch diese EM habe ich alle gesehen. Das ist der finanzielle Wert, den ich dann abgleiche mit was würde es mich kosten, wenn ich die Karten gekauft hätte und hinzu kommt, dass ich eben da auf der Presse-Tribüne stehe, auf Höhe der Mittellinie und dort einen super Blick habe und nicht irgendwo hinten im Oberrang hinter der Kurve, wo ich ohne meine Brille kaum noch was sehe.
Aber bist du da nicht auch privilegiert, weil es gibt ja auch die Volontiers, die die ganze Zeit vorm Stadion sind.
Oder am Hauptbahnhof.
Oder am Hauptbahnhof oder in der Fan-Zone, wobei die zumindest das Spiel ja noch am Fernsehen sehen. Aber ich kenne auch einige Volontiers, die tatsächlich am Nordteil der Münchner Arena quasi am Eingang zum Stadion standen, zum Durchgang zum Parkplatz, wo jetzt auch wirklich nichts dann los ist. Und wenn du dann im Hintergrund nur die Geräusche des Spiels hörst, aber nichts davon mitbekommst, das ist dann schon irgendwie, also das würde ich auch nicht machen wollen. Ja, meine Position ist natürlich privilegiert und qua Erfahrung weiß ich, was ich machen muss, um dann in die Lage zu kommen, auch die Spiele zu sehen. Das ist wirklich eine sehr, sehr schwierige Frage, die jeder für sich selber beantworten muss. Ein kleiner Fakt ist, nach dem Eröffnungsspiel sind, glaube ich, und jetzt möchte ich mich nicht an der Zahl aufhängen, aber mindestens 60 Volontiers sind bald zum nächsten Spiel nicht mehr erschienen.
Ja gut, aber da gab es ja auch zum Beispiel die Geschichte, auch durch Marvin Wildhage aufgedeckt mehr oder weniger, dass denjenigen, die da bei der Eröffnungsthermonie helfen sollte, noch gesagt wurde, ihr dürft danach das Spiel gucken und als ihnen dann nach drei Tagen Probe mit dem großen Plan, die sie ausrollen sollten, gesagt wurde, ach so, ihr dürft das Spiel übrigens doch nicht sehen, ist da eben auch ein Drittel der Leute nicht mehr erschienen und man kann es ihnen sehr gut verdenken, denn es ist ja auch ein sozialer Selektor, wie Sofiles. Also man kann ja auch sagen, dieses Volunteering, so wie du es sagst, gibt einem ja auch die Möglichkeit, dabei zu sein und jetzt sind ja sowieso schon zum Beispiel arme Menschen ausgeschlossen von dieser EM. Da helfen auch keine Fans first 30 Euro-Tickets, denn auch 30 Euro können sehr, sehr viel Geld sein für viele Menschen. Das finde ich schon schade. Hast du denn, wie divers fandest du denn, wann die Volunteers aufgestellt sind? Mein Eindruck war schon, dass das so, ein bisschen habe ich mich gefühlt, wie als ich mal in Brüssel war und da lauter Erasmus-Studenten und eben irgendwelche PraktikantInnen von EU-Abgeordneten rumliefen. Es schien mir schon so eine Studenten-Truppe zu sein. Also jetzt, ich schäre jetzt über einen Kamm, aber so im Durchschnitt.
Ja absolut, sehe ich genau so. Also jetzt, wo du es sagst, sehe ich von meinem inneren Auge das Team des Akkreditierungs-Centers und also besonders divers waren wir jetzt nicht. Also ich gehörte da schon zu den Älteren und ansonsten, wie du sagst, viele Studenten.
Mir ist es nämlich insofern aufgefallen, weil wir sehen das ja eigentlich beim Fußball. Vielleicht hat man nur gelernt, wegzusehen. Im Kontext von Großveranstaltungen, zu denen Fußball gehört, siehst du sehr oft alte Menschen und du siehst auch oft Menschen, die ganz offensichtlich nicht zu den Besserverdienern der Gesellschaft gehören. Das sind nämlich diejenigen, die sich ums Pfand prügeln fast schon. Und es ist mir wirklich aufgefallen, dass das bei dieser EM wieder auch so war. Aber ab einer gewissen Grenze, nämlich dieser äußere Ring, wo dann die Tickets kontrolliert werden, hast du ein homogeneres Publikum, so wie es bei der Bundesliga aussieht. Ich will es jetzt nicht der EM vorwerfen. Matthias, hast du da Gedanken zu? Wir beide begleiten das Ganze ja auch journalistisch. Es ist eine uralte Frage, die bei jedem Turnier aufgeworfen wird. Warum gibt es auf der einen Seite Milliardengewinn und auf der anderen Seite dennoch keinen monetären Ertrag? Wie denkst du darüber?
Die Frage mit dem Milliardengewinn und dem monetären Ertrag, die stellen sich ja viele. Das ist noch mal ein anderes Thema, wenn man über Gastgeberstädte oder irgendwas redet. Das ist glaube ich so, ich will nicht sagen Fehler, sondern vielleicht einfach Grundkonstruktionen von solchen Großereignissen, dass die Ausrichter, also die großen Sportverbände, das natürlich erst mal als Kommerz verstehen und dass das das einzige Thema ist, was eigentlich zählt. Im Endeffekt, wir hatten es ja gerade schon so ein bisschen bei dem Thema Schwarzmarkt oder Nicht-Schwarzmarkt auch. Also es geht im Ende ja nur darum, dass die Tasche möglichst dick ist. Und dann ist es ja auch erstmal egal, wie sie dick wird. Also ganz anderes Thema, aber dass Cricket jetzt olympisch wird, ist ja klar. Warum? Weil da ein Riesenmarkt hinter steht. Also das liegt ja auf der Hand. Und jetzt bei der Europameisterschaft. Ich habe bei einer Veranstaltung den Martin Kallen getroffen oder einen Vortrag von ihm zugehört. Das war ein halbes Jahr vor der EM. Martin Kallen ist der für die Events zuständige CEO bei der Uefa. Toller Titel auch. Und der hat halt ein halbes Jahr vor der EM gesagt, also sie sind ausverkauft. Das Turnier ist jetzt schon ein Erfolg. Die Fernsehrechte sind weg. Die Sponsoren-Deals sind vergebens. Das Einzige, was sie irgendwie noch verkaufen müssen, sind kleinere Rechte-Pakete irgendwo in Südasien oder so, wo irgendwie für zwei Länder noch Verträge abgeschlossen werden müssen. Aber da reden wir dann über Peanuts im Vergleich zu dem globalen Markt. Also das ist klar, es geht nur um die Kohle. Und dann ist es auch egal, wer das Publikum ist. Hauptsache, sie machen keinen Stress. Das ist, glaube ich, entscheidend. Also bitte keine politischen Botschaften. Zumindest keine, die irgendwie wehtun. Bitte keine Ausschreitungen, keine Krawalle, kein irgendwas. Und bitte viel Geld überweisen. Der Rest ist eigentlich egal. Es klingt fatalistisch, aber ich glaube, es ist einfach so.
Joel, du wolltest noch was sagen?
Ja, ich wollte nochmal auf die Diversität zurückkommen. Denn tatsächlich konnten wir ja offensichtlich sehen, dass bei den Volunteers das jetzt nicht so massiv war. Aber da, wo die Diversität tatsächlich stattfand, war bei den gewerblichen Ordnern. Denn da hattest du massiv Leute mit Migrationshintergrund. Da waren nicht mehr die, und jetzt sage ich es wirklich plakativ, die weißen jungen Studenten, sondern da hattest du alle anderen, die dann für 12,50 Euro die Stunde irgendwo umstehen mussten.
Da gab es ja auch ein massives Rekrutierungsproblem. Das ist ja im Vorfeld auch tatsächlich thematisiert worden, dass sie massiv suchen mussten und echt Schwierigkeiten hatten, welche zu finden und dass dann auch die Schulungsstufen möglicherweise nicht bei allen so gegeben waren, wie man sich das hätte vorstellen wollen.
Und das waren dann die, die im schlimmsten Fall mit dem Rücken zum Spielfeld stehen mussten, um irgendwelche Flitze abzufangen und dann noch irgendwie ausgelacht wurden, wenn sie die Flitze nicht bekommen haben vom ganzen Stadion bejubelt. Das war schon sehr auffällig. Matthias, du wolltest noch was ergänzen?
Ja, weil du gerade Flitzer sagst. Ich fand es interessant. Ich habe dieses Flitzer-Thema. Ich hatte ja ganz, ganz wirklich einen mini kurzen Werbeblock. Ich hatte ja eine lange Sendung zum Finale im Deutschlandfunk, fünf Stunden, wo du auch dabei warst, Max. Und da hatte ich Markus Stenger im Interview. Das ist ja der Chef-Organisator, kann man sagen, der Geschäftsführer dieser Euro GmbH. Und den habe ich nach den Flitzern gefragt, inwieweit er eigentlich immer Schweißperlen auf den Stirn hatte, wenn Ronaldo gespielt hat. Und das fand ich dann ganz interessant eigentlich, dass er da so offen war und das erzählt hat. Der hat gesagt, also sie hätten dann schon immer darüber geredet und auch immer nachjustiert das Konzept und hätten während der EM die Positionen der Ordner angepasst, weil sie gemerkt haben, da müssen wir ein bisschen nachhelfen. Und sie wären dann dazu übergegangen und hätten schnellere Ordner auf wichtige Positionen getan. Und ihr lacht alle, ich musste auch ein bisschen lachen. Ich habe mir das dann wirklich vorgestellt, gab es irgendwie einen 50 Meter Ausscheidungsrennen, der im Unterrang stehen musste oder so. Also tatsächlich haben die sich über solche Fragen wirklich Gedanken gemacht. Er hat aber auch gesagt, es sei von Anfang an nicht das Ziel gewesen, hermetisch das Spielfeld abzuriegeln und einen richtigen Ring zu ziehen. Das hätten sie auch nicht gewollt. Und er hat dann auch nochmal gesagt, dass dann minderjährige Kinder sogar die Zahl 8 Jahre ins Spiel gebracht, von den Eltern toleriert, mit einem Handy aufs Spielfeld geschickt werden, ist natürlich einfach auch nochmal ein ganz anderes Thema. Aber diese Frage der Schnelligkeit der Ordner ist mir auf jeden Fall noch mal hängen geblieben gestern.
Und dann der Typ, der da runterspringt aus 3, 4 Metern Höhe. Ich habe es nur bei TikTok gesehen. Aber das war wirklich schon next-level crazy.
Also das war ein Fan, der eben in den Abgang in der Arena auf Schalke, war es glaube ich, auf die Treppenstufen, runtergesprungen ist, neben Cristiano Ronaldo und ihm knapp verfählten Ordner.
Tackelt ihn halt weg. Der hat nicht die 100-Meter-Sprint oder 50-Meter-Sprint vortesten lassen, sondern die Tackle-Fähigkeit wahrscheinlich. Das war schon... Ich habe mich irgendwie hinreißen lassen, weil ich nach Spielzehen voll wenig Flitzer hatte. Und ich glaube, danach kamen sie alle. Wie nach Stadion allerdings.
Es gibt flitzerfreundliche und unfreundliche Stadien. Dort ist man extrem flitzerfreudig, aber in Gelsenkirchen gar keine Chance. Eintracht in Frankfurt, da habe ich ein Portugalspiel gesehen. Da habe ich sehr genau drauf geachtet. Da hatten sie aber auch eine Doppelreihe platziert. Das war ganz interessant. Sie haben nicht nur die Geschwindigkeit der Ordner, sondern auch den Deckungsschatten genutzt. Da gab es eine Reihe, die vorne stand, und eine Reihe, die noch mal zwei Meter dahinter stand. Sie haben offenbar das WM-System verwendet für die EM. Früheres Gegenpressing. Wie denkst du, Tobi, als regelmäßiger Stadiongänger, darüber, dass viele Fangzäune nicht zu sehen waren? Was auf der einen Seite dazu geführt hat, sehr viele Bierbecher, die geflogen sind, bei Spielen aller Art, muss man dankbar sein, dass da nichts Schlimmeres passiert ist. Einer wurde, glaube ich, von einer Münze getroffen. War das ein österreichischer Spieler? Genau, hat aber keine große Nummer draus gemacht. Auf der anderen Seite hat man aber auch im Stadion schon gesehen, wie schön das sein kann. Wie denkst du darüber?
Ja, wie schön das sein kann. Als jemand, der von den 21 Spielen, ich habe es nicht mitgezählt, wahrscheinlich mindestens 15 im Bereich hinter dem Tor gesehen hat, eher auf den günstigeren Plätzen, und da fehlt dann halt das Netz. Das ist ein kompletter Gamechanger. Also um das Spiel vernünftig zu gucken. Ich war am Ende der letzten Saison in Augsburg, bei Augsburg gegen Bremen. Ich weiß nicht, warum es mich da so unfassbar gestört hat. Da saßen wir im Oberrang hinter dem Tor, also nicht da, wo die Heimtribüne, sondern wo die Gästefans mehr so sind. Man kennt es aus Gästeblöcken, aber da war ein riesengroßes und auch total störendes Netz aufgezogen in Augsburg damals. Diese ganzen Netze wurden alle, wie du gerade gesagt hast, abgebaut zur Euro und oh mein Gott, wie viel besser ist das zum Gucken? Dazu kam noch, dass die ganzen Gäste-Block-Zäune auch ab oder zumindest sehr, sehr weit runtergebaut wurden. Das heißt, du hattest nie dieses Eingesperrt-Gefühl, dieses Gäste-Heim-Trennungs-Gefühl, dieser Bereich, dieser Bereich, wir, die. Sondern es war einfach ein Stadion für alle Leute und du konntest von überall ohne Störung, also Grüße nach Berlin, klar sind da so ein paar Pfeiler, damit das Dach nicht einstürzt. Muss sagen, keine Frage, kann nicht jeder ganz gut gucken, aber grundsätzlich, ihr wisst, was ich meine, es ist einfach ein riesengroßes Upgrade gewesen für Stadion-Erlebnis, dass diese Zäune oder diese Netze dort nicht mehr sind. Und ja, Becher sind geflogen. Ich habe aber auch das Gefühl, dass Becher auch in der Bundesliga und in der zweiten Liga fliegen. Wir können jetzt gerne eine Diskussion und da muss sich vielleicht einer hinsetzen und eine Strichliste führen, wo es jetzt öfter war und wo es weniger war. Aber ganz ehrlich, liebe DFL, vielleicht ist das mal ein Versuch, dass man sagt, wir gucken mal, was eine Saison lang passiert, wenn wir diese Netze weglassen, ob dann wirklich so viel fliegt. Denn Tennisbälle und Münzen gehen offensichtlich ja trotzdem durch. Also lasst sie doch weg. Es war so, so viel schöner, muss ich sagen. Auch diese Zäune im Unterrang, die erste Reihe, die dann, ich glaube, in München im normalen Spielbetrieb ist da auch ein Zaun. Bei der Euro ist da nix. Es ist so, so viel besser. Es hat mega viel Spaß gemacht.
Wobei dann natürlich im Liga-Betrieb, jetzt gerade in München, eigentlich auch Stehplätze sind. Das ist ja das nächste Thema. Wie gut hätte diese EM noch sein können, wenn Stehplätze erlaubt gewesen wären? Ich meine, die gelbe Wand, die dann die türkisch-rote Wand gewesen wäre. Wie fantastisch.
Aber sind Stehplätze der Grund dafür, dass die Netze hin müssen?
Nee, ich habe jetzt quasi die Zäune unten gemeint. Das, glaube ich, ist dann schon was anderes, wenn die Menschen nicht sitzen, sondern stehen. Dann brauchst du auf jeden Fall irgendeine Art von Wellenbrecher und Schutz nach vorne. Das dachte ich jetzt.
Aber die Netze kann man doch trotzdem weglassen.
Wegen mir könnte man sie weglassen. Joel wird es wahrscheinlich eh nicht sehen. Es ist egal, wo er im Stadion steht. Der hat immer beste Sicht. Und Matthias und ich, wir sitzen sowieso auf der Presse-Tribüne. Uns passiert da nichts. Aber wie war denn euer Sicherheitsempfinden bei dieser EM? Man könnte jetzt ja auch argumentieren, naja, die Gründe, warum es all diese Vorkehrungen, inklusive Käfige für Gästefans gibt, ist ja auch, es passiert ja hin und wieder doch was in der Bundesliga. Nicht so viel, wie einem immer Glauben gemacht werden will. Aber es ist definitiv so, dass auch etwas passiert. Wie viele Situationen, Joel, hattest du denn bei dieser EM? Wer hat sich im Pressebereich geprügelt?
Ich habe nichts mitbekommen. Ich hatte relativ guten Draht zu den Sicherheitskräften, weil wir im Akkreditierungscenter immer zwei Beamte vom LKA sitzen hatten, die ja die Ausweise gecheckt haben. Die haben auch immer so ein bisschen geplaudert. Es gab nichts, kaum etwas Berichtenswertes.
Matthias, wie war das bei dir? Ich erinnere mich, dass wir, glaube ich, bei der EM 2016 darüber gesprochen haben, gerade über die hohe Polizeipräsenz inklusive Maschinengewehr usw. Wie war es bei dir, diese EM?
Ja, 2016 war es natürlich so, dass das quasi unmittelbar nach den Anschlägen war, Stichwort Bataclan und Stade de France und so. Dieses Mal, das haben wir auch zum Thema gemacht vorher, also Sicherheit war ja eigentlich das Thema bis zum Eröffnungsspieltag. Und in Deutschland allein durch Föderalismus und Co. funktioniert das ja ein bisschen anders, wie das so mit Sicherheitskräften und Polizei und Militär vor allen Dingen auch funktioniert, eben deutlich weniger als in Frankreich. Ich habe mich sehr sicher gefühlt, es war ja auch überhaupt kein Thema. Es gab ja keine einzige Nachricht oder irgendwas, dass jetzt was los sein könnte oder dass es eine Bedrohung oder irgendwas gibt. Also das fand ich eine der erstaunlichsten Geschichten dieses Turniers, dass es überhaupt kein Thema war. Also bis zum Eröffnungstag hat man darüber geredet und geredet und geredet. Und alle, selbst die Innenminister haben irgendwie gesagt, ja es gibt eine abstrakte Bedrohung. Und dann hieß es eine abstrakte, die ins Konkrete geht. Und da hat man sich ja an diplomatischen Formulierungen täglich überboten irgendwie, wie man es jetzt so ausdrückt, dass alle Leute wissen, okay, sie nehmen es ernst, aber es ist jetzt nicht schlimm. Und mit dem ersten Spiel, mit dem Anpfiff in München, war das Thema weg und kam auch nicht wieder.
Es kam nochmal kurz nach Marvin-Wil-Tages-Aktion.
Ja, aber auf einer anderen Ebene. Also so noch der Motto, da müssen wir nochmal nachschärfen. Und wenn jetzt wirklich einer wirklich finstere Absichten gehabt hätte, ja, war aber dann vielleicht auch nochmal ein Weckruf. Also da nochmal nachzugucken. Und danach kam es ja nicht mehr, ehrlich. Also das war echt so eine Überraschung, fand ich, dass das kein Thema mehr war.
Ich würde gerne zwei, drei Sachen dazu sagen. Auf der einen Seite dieses im Stadion-Erlebnis. Ich habe mich tatsächlich nie unwohl gefühlt zu keinem Zeitpunkt. Auch wenn wir nochmal auf diese Gästeblog-Einsperrgeschichte kommen. Es scheint ja offensichtlich möglich zu sein, dass Fans verschiedener Fanlager, verschiedener Nationen in diesem Fall zusammen anreisen zum Stadion. Dass nicht irgendwie getrennte, von Polizei begleitete Aktionen stattfinden müssen. Dass sie im Stadion nebeneinander sitzen. Das ließe ich einfach auch gar nicht verhindern. Wir haben vorhin über den Zweitmarkt der Tickets gesprochen. Das zog sich ja bis zum Finale durch, wo der Spanien-Blog teilweise große, große Teile von englischen Fans drin hatte. Es ist möglich offensichtlich Fußball zu genießen, ohne dass man sich mit dem Gegner im Stadion irgendwie in die Wolle kriegt. Und ich habe das Gefühl, dieses Turnier hat das über ganz, ganz breite Teile gezeigt. Es gab sicherlich auch einzelne Ausnahmen. Wenn man an den entsprechenden Stellen sucht, findet man bestimmt irgendjemand, der sich im Stadion mit irgendjemandem anders kurz in die Haare kriegt. Aber im Großen und Ganzen war es möglich, den Stadionbesuch gemeinsam zu erleben und gemeinsam so durchzuziehen, dass nichts passiert. Das ist das eine. Das andere ist das, Matthias hat es gerade angesprochen, das Sicherheitsgefühl. Ich habe auch vor dem Turnier an 2016 gedacht. Und auch damals, wo Freunde abgesagt haben oder gesagt haben, ich fahre nicht nach Frankreich, das ist mir alles im Moment ein bisschen unsicher, habe ich mich vor dem Turnier auch zurück daran erinnert und dachte mir, dieses Jahr ist eigentlich relativ ruhig, ist das eigentlich ein gutes oder ein schlechtes Zeichen. In dem Fall war es tatsächlich ein gutes Zeichen. Ich fühlte mich von Spiel eins bis zum Ende durch. An keiner Stelle irgendwie so, dass ich gedacht habe, es ist irgendwie eine Gefahr da oder ich fühle mich an dieser Stelle nicht sicher. Ich fand tatsächlich, es war relativ große Polizeipräsenz, sowohl in den Stadien als auch in den Städten selber. Was ich spannend fand, war, dass ich viele Polizisten und Polizistinnen gesehen habe, aus den Ländern, wo die teilnehmenden Mannschaften da waren. Da hast du ja dann irgendwie auch hier oben die Fahne oder keine Ahnung, da steht dann da Polizia drauf, Polizia Lokal für die Spanier und solche Geschichten. Also viele Länder haben offensichtlich in Kooperation mit der deutschen Polizei eigene Polizisten geschickt, was glaube ich dann häufig dafür auch gesorgt hat, dass, wenn man Ansprechpartner brauchte als Spanier, als weiß ich nicht, wo sie alle herkamen, dass man das auch gefunden hat und dass es vielleicht ein bisschen deeskalierend die ganze Geschichte war. Trotz allem auch, ja, es gab auch genug Szenen, habe ich auch gesehen, wo die Polizei wirklich nicht lang gefackelt hat. Also dann meistens die deutsche Polizei, wenn es irgendwie zu Problemen gab, dann sind die halt schnell dazwischen gegangen und dann wurden irgendwelche Pyros auf irgendwelchen Fan-Merschen ausgemacht. Muss auch alles nicht sein, aber das Einzige Geschichten, ja, gibt es viele, aber im Großen und Ganzen fand ich, war das ein Turnier, was erfreulich, ruhig und problemlos abgelaufen ist, was das Thema Sicherheit angeht.
Und den Eindruck scheint ja auch Joel gehabt zu haben, du hast es ja vorhin schon so ein bisschen angedeutet, trotz den aus dem Nähkästchen plaudernden LKA-Beamten, es war wenig zu sehen, mit ganz wenigen Ausnahmen. Interessant fand ich, wie die Uefa selbst stolz war auf die Fan-Märsche, die man veranstaltet hat. Ich meine, das waren ja auch die Bilder, die vor den Spielen vor allem weiter rumherum gehen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele Videos von niederländischen Fans ich gesehen habe, die nach links und nach rechts hüpfen, aber ja auch von vielen, vielen anderen. Ich fand es einfach interessant, wie die Uefa das selbst vermarktet hat in ihrer Pressemitteilung rund um das Finale, wie viele Menschen da auch teilgenommen hätten an diesen Fanmarschen und so weiter und so fort. Aber dann lass doch mal noch so langsam abschließend generell über dieses Turnier sprechen. Was waren eure schönsten Erlebnisse? Was wird bleiben? Und Matthias, vielleicht an dich noch die Frage. Wir haben jetzt den Journalismus-Part nur bei der Akkreditierung quasi besprochen. Vielleicht müssten wir das noch kurz machen. Wie hast du denn die Arbeit empfunden jetzt vor Ort bei diesem Turnier?
Als sehr angenehm. Es gibt ja die verschiedenen Bereiche sozusagen. Einmal im Stadion und einmal, was man so außenrum hat, wenn es dann irgendwie an Interviews oder an Recherchen geht. Im Stadion eigentlich total professionell. Keine irgendwie Beeinträchtigungen. Also man lässt sich ja, wenn man bei so einem Turnier mitmacht, lässt man sich ja auf die Bedingungen der Uefa oder auch der FIFA bei einer WM ein. Da muss man ja grundsätzlich erstmal sagen, das ist ja schon ein Korsett, in dem man sich bewegt. Es gibt Wege, auf dem man laufen darf, auf dem man nicht laufen darf. Bis hin zum Stadion, WLAN, was man benutzen muss. Die FIFA zum Beispiel hat ja verboten damals, ich weiß gar nicht, wie es diesmal hier war, dass man eigene Hotspots macht. Ich glaube, diesmal war es erlaubt oder es war okay.
Stand nicht im Code of Contact dran. Und da stand ja ansonsten alles drin.
In Qatar war es nämlich verboten, da durfte man keine eigenen Hotspots machen. Da musste man das Stadion und WLAN benutzen, sonst hat man direkt Ärger bekommen. Habe ich zwar auch nicht mitbekommen, dass das passiert ist, aber das stand halt da drin. Also man lässt sich ja auf so Rahmenbedingungen ein. Und innerhalb dieser Rahmenbedingungen war alles total einfach zu lösen. Das war alle freundlich, auch die von der Uefa und alle, die dann offiziell auf den Tribünen waren. Das war alles sehr, sehr, ja, auf einer sehr okayen Ebene. Da war nichts irgendwie, was problematisch war. Und außen drum rum muss man, glaube ich, zwei Dinge unterscheiden. Einmal die Uefa und einmal was sonst war. Die meisten hatten irgendwie Interesse, was zu sagen. Die meisten hatten Interesse, sich zu äußern zu den Themen. Selbst die Stadt Gelsenkirchen, die ziemlich angezählt wurde, nach dem Desaster des ersten Spiels, hat sich sehr offen gezeigt, hat dann auch für Interviews zur Verfügung gestanden usw. usf. Also das war eigentlich, alle hatten irgendwie Interesse, bei diesem Turnier dann auch ihren Beitrag zu leisten, auch ein Stück von diesem Aufmerksamkeitskuchen zu bekommen. Nur die Uefa, und auch das ist leider nichts Neues, Anfragen sehr schnell beantwortet. Ja, aber nur schriftlich, keine O-Töne, keine Videobilder, keine Interviews, ich habe nochmal angefragt, auch zum Finale nichts zu kriegen, keine Interviews, nichts geplant. Dann hieß es am Anfang irgendwie so, ja, wir prüfen das noch, aber da war eigentlich schon klar, das wird es nicht geben. Und dass es auch keine Schlusspressekonferenz am Ende gibt, wo man mal Fragen stellen kann, das finde ich, das haben sie sich von der FIFA abgeguckt, das finde ich inzwischen auch, ja, ich sage es mal so deutlich unverschämt, weil hier hinkommen, die Milliardengewinne einstreichen und dann nicht mal eine oder anderthalb Stunden Zeit haben, um nochmal ein paar Themen zu besprechen. Was sollen sie dadurch verlieren? Also sie haben sogar die Gelegenheit, ihre Sicht der Dinge nochmal darzustellen. Pressemitteilung ist natürlich einfacher, aber die anderthalb Stunden könnten sich schon noch Zeit nehmen, finde ich.
Also ich muss sagen, das ist mir auch richtig aufgefallen, weil ich habe da richtig drauf gewartet, weil ich da auch schon in Berlin war und mir dachte, ah, da könnte ich kommen, wenn die am Samstag da Cheferin hinsetzen, dann könnte ich da hingehen. Aber ich hätte ja auch keine Frage stellen können. Kannst du mir erklären, nach welchen Kriterien die Uefa-Mitarbeitenden, also es geht jetzt nicht um die Verband-Mitarbeitenden, die machen das ja anders, aber bei Matchday-1, also einen Tag vor dem Spiel und am Spieltag selbst, da sind es ja die Uefa-Offiziellen, die dann auswählen, wer da Fragen stellen darf. Kannst du mir erklären, warum ich keine einzige Frage stellen durfte bei diesem Turnier? Was mache ich falsch, Matthias?
Vielleicht kann Joel das besser beantworten, aber ich weiß es nicht. Ich hatte bei den Pressekonferenzen rund um die Spiele, wo ich war, immer das Gefühl, es liegt an der Position, wo man sitzt, an der Art, wie man winkt.
Ich saß irgendwann nur noch in der ersten Reihe.
Okay, da hätte ich jetzt deine Chance relativ hoch eingeschätzt, aber ich weiß nicht, ob die nach irgendwelchen Kriterien dann auch, also ob die sich die Menschen quasi einfach angucken und entscheiden, wer jetzt zu den betreffenden Ländern gehört oder ob dann die Nationalverbände irgendwelche Gesichter davor markieren für die Uefa, die auf jeden Fall Fragen stellen dürfen. Ich weiß es nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Also ich war dann irgendwann nicht mehr bei allen Pressekonferenzen, weil da habe ich ja dann oft schon meine Sendung im Stadion gemacht, damit es für die Gäste nicht zu schwer wird, aber zu spät wird. Aber ich war zum Beispiel bei allen deutschen Spielen und eben genau nachdem ich beim ersten Spiel nicht dran kam, habe ich mich beim zweiten direkt in die vorderste Reihe gesetzt. Und beim Spanien-Spiel war es am interessantesten. Da habe ich mich gleich gemeldet, als die Uefa-Offizielle angefangen hat zu sprechen, die kannte mich auch schon, und sie hat direkt mit dem Kopf geschüttelt. Dann dachte ich mir, okay, was habe ich falsch gemacht? Und dann durfte der Kollege von der Nordasie-Zeitung seine erste Frage stellen, und ich will jetzt überhaupt nicht Medien gegeneinander ausspielen oder so. Die Frage war auch eine gute. Aber es ist dann doch frustrierend, weil natürlich kann man in Herzogenaurach beim DFB da nach allem, was ich gehört habe, durfte da jeder so viele Fragen stellen, wie er wollte. Mir ist da jetzt nichts zu Ohren gekommen, dass es da irgendwelche Probleme gegeben hätte. Aber für diejenigen, die eben nicht nur über ein Team berichten, sondern eben an jedem Spieltag mit anderen Teams zu tun haben, wann soll man mal eine Frage stellen dürfen, als in so einer Pressekonferenz? Das fand ich ein bisschen interessant. Ist jetzt nicht so, also ich werde jetzt nicht deswegen heulend in meinem Kämmerchen sitzen. Aber nicht ganz so, wie man sich wünschen würde. Auch bei einem Verständnis dafür, dass die Trainer keine Stunde Zeit haben nach dem Spiel, das ist mir schon auch klar. Und zweiter Aspekt, den ich zumindest erwähnenswert finde, also wir haben Umbauten gesehen in Stadien, unter anderem in Stuttgart, wurde sehr lange umgebaut, aber offenbar hat man die Mixed Zone nicht groß genug gemacht. Denn während ich in allen Stadien immer in die Mixed Zone durfte, war es in Stuttgart ausgerechnet beim Spiel gegen Spanien, wo es mal interessant gewesen wäre zu hören, was die deutschen Spieler da gesagt hätten. Da wurde dann voselektiert, weil eben die Mixed Zone zu klein war. Ich weiß nicht, Matthias, ob du da auch vor Ort warst bei dem Spiel. Fand ich zumindest unbegriffen.
Bei dem Spiel war ich nicht. Aber das ist tatsächlich auch noch so eine Beobachtung, wenn du das gerade sagst. Mixed Zone und Pressekonferenzen, ja normalerweise ein größeres Thema, ein heikleres Thema, braucht man da irgendwie, weil sonst bei den Turnieren irgendwie extra Karten und kommt dann irgendwie gar nicht rein. Und das war dieses Mal ja sehr unkompliziert gelöst. In Berlin beispielsweise war die Pressekonferenz einfach mitten im Medienzentrum. Da konnte jeder einfach hin, wenn er wollte, in München ähnlich gelöst. Das fand ich ein bisschen barrierefreier tatsächlich. In Stuttgart hab ich es gar nicht erst probiert, weil ich da bei dem Spiel, wo ich relativ schnell wieder weg musste, da haben wir uns auch getroffen sogar.
Ja stimmt, ich erinnere mich.
Dieses unglaublich beeindruckende 7 zu 7 zwischen Belgien und der Ukraine, was wir da gesehen haben. Nach Fauls war es ein 7. Nach Fauls, ja. Und das fand ich tatsächlich irgendwie interessant, dass das klar auch vorsortiert wurde, wer in die erste Reihe durfte, in der Mixzone oder so, aber dass das da relativ barrierefrei war und man da ganz gut hin konnte.
Da kann ich noch eine kleine Anekdote hinterherschieben. Im München, im Presseraum, wie du sagst, der Pressekonferenzraum war ja mit dem Medienarbeitsraum quasi kontingent. Die Idee der Uefa-Anzug-Tragenden war, dass, wenn die Pressekonferenz läuft, die Türen geschlossen bleiben sollen. Also niemand mehr rein und raus geht, woraufhin der Ordnungsdienst, der dort arbeitet, den Herren und Damen von der Uefa erklärt hat, das können wir nicht machen, denn wir können die Leute nicht ihrer Freiheit beraubend kommen, um zu gehen, wie sie wollen. Und da waren die Damen und Herren aus der Schweiz doch leicht pikiert, dass da Geräusche öffnender Türen stattfinden.
Ja, es war interessant, wie auch die unterschiedlichen Uefa-Offiziellen das unterschiedlich gehandhabt haben. Ich war auch bei einigen Remote-Pressekonferenzen mit dabei. Da hieß es eigentlich auch, man darf zwei Fragen werden immer noch mal von den Remote-Anwesenden, Journalistinnen gestellt. Das habe ich bei einer Pressekonferenz erlebt, bei allen anderen haben die da gar nicht mehr angeguckt. Andererseits, wenn aber schon so viele Fragen gestellt wurden, dass die Zeit vorbei ist. Also ich will da jetzt auch gar nicht so ein großes Thema draus machen. Es gibt wirklich viel, viel wichtigere Themen rund um diese EM. Aber es war immerhin interessant. Ansonsten muss ich allerdings sagen, weil mich das auch einige Hörerinnen gefragt hatten, die Sendung aus dem Stadion herauszumachen. Ich hatte mir das viel problematischer vorgestellt. Als Annika bei der Frauen-WM in Australien war, da wurde sie regelmäßig verscheucht von Menschen, die gesagt haben, du musst jetzt hier abbauen. Warum sitzt du hier noch 15 Minuten nach Schlusspfiff? Und bei mir war es so, dass ich meine Sendung, weil ich festgestellt habe, dass das Kabelnetzwerk auf dem Pressetribünen viel, viel schneller war, als das WLAN, das zur Verfügung stand, vor allem im Upload. Der Upload war fantastisch. Deswegen habe ich meine Sendung dann immer komplett fertig produziert, damit ich das YouTube-Video schon mal hochladen kann, weil das irgendwie bei 8 GB hat es so 16 Minuten oder so gedauert. Und im Kloster in Krefer, der ich da für drei Tage gebraucht, wo ich unter anderem ja genächtigt habe. Und das war total angenehm. Ich hatte das vor dem Eröffnungsspiel noch mit jemandem besprochen, mit der Leiterin des Mediencenters. Und die meinte, du kannst da draußen sitzen bleiben, solange du willst. Und tatsächlich so war es. Und die haben dann auch in den Stadien, in denen ich war, ich glaube, ich war in vier Stadien an deren letzten Spieltag und habe da eine Sendung im Stadion gemacht. Und um mich herum wurde dann schon die komplette Pressetribüne abgebaut. Inklusive Netzwerkdosen. Einmal haben sie mir mein Bildschirm weggetragen. Das fand ich ein bisschen schade. Also war nicht meiner persönlich, sondern der, der auf meinem Platz stand. Aber ansonsten haben die wirklich um mich herum abgebaut. Und in Frankfurt ganz herzliche Grüße nochmal. Haben sie extra versucht, leise zu sein, als sie diese Klettverschluss-Dinge von den Tribünenhalterungen weggemacht haben. Also das hat sehr, sehr gut funktioniert. Und dass ich auch bis weit nach offizieller Stadion-Schließung manchmal im Stadion bleiben konnte, fand ich auch sehr angenehm. Weil so konnte ich fertig produzieren. Also in Dortmund zum Beispiel wäre um zwei Schluss gewesen. Gut klar, da gab es noch die Gewitterunterbrechung. Aber ich glaube, ich bin da um vier raus oder so. Also da waren dann auch nicht mehr viele Leute. Die haben auch alle ein bisschen irritiert geguckt. In Köln habe ich einen Ordner und ich, wir haben uns fürchterlich gegenseitig erschrocken, weil wir beide zeitgleich ums Eck gekommen sind im sonst komplett leeren Stadiumklo. Er wollte einen Kontrollgang machen und ich wollte etwas anderes erledigen, bevor ich auf die Autobahn gehe. Wir sind fürchterlich beide erschrocken. Aber das fand ich sehr angenehm, dass man wirklich da arbeiten konnte und dass auch alle, die gesehen haben, du bist gerade am Arbeiten, die haben das auch respektiert und haben dich jetzt nicht irgendwie zugetextet. Das soll auch schon mal anders gewesen sein. Das ist schon ziemlich nah dran an meinem schönsten Erlebnis bei dieser EM. Nein, das ist natürlich ein Quatsch. Aber ich wollte noch von euch die schönsten Erlebnisse einsammeln. Tobi, du darfst mal vorlegen, ihr könnt auch alle mehrfach dran kommen, wenn es so viele sind. Was glaubst du, wird dir in Erinnerung bleiben von dieser EM?
Also grundsätzlich, dass es möglich ist, so viele Mannschaften, nämlich 24 Stück, und dementsprechend dann auch die dazugehörigen Fans alle in ein Land zu bringen und so ein Turnier durchzuführen, ohne dass es zu größeren Problemen kommt. Meine persönlichen Erfahrungen sind, dass es eigentlich immer gut war, dass die Leute immer gut waren, wenn man mit den Leuten vernünftig gesprochen hat und offen auf sie zugegangen ist, dass man genauso offen auch empfangen wurde. Und eine richtig gute Zeit, unabhängig davon, welches Trikot du gerade anhast oder für welche Mannschaft du bist, haben konnte. Und das zog sich tatsächlich vom ersten Spiel, ok, Deutschland, Schottland, da sind wir mal alle davon ausgegangen, dass es genauso kommen wird, dass alle Spaß haben, sich auf dem Marienplatz ordentlich einreienscheppern und dann alle zum Stadion fahren und es wird eine gute, gute Zeit. Aber es hat dann halt wirklich auch die anderen Spiele genauso geklappt. Und ich möchte vielleicht ein Spiel, was neben dem Platz für mich so das Besonderste war, herausheben, das war das Viertelfinale, ja, das war das Viertelfinale, das Achtelfinale, Türkei gegen Österreich in Leipzig. Mein einziger Besuch in Leipzig, mein insgesamt erst zweiter Stadionbesuch in Leipzig, Matthias, du nix, wir haben uns dort nach dem Spiel dann noch im Umlauf kurz getroffen. Das war alles das, was passiert ist, bevor diese Geschichte mit dem Wolfsgruß publik wurde. Also wir im Stadion, ich habe es nicht mitgekriegt, ich habe da jetzt auch nicht groß aufs Handy geguckt, und ich glaube, es war auch während des Spiels kein größeres Thema. Das heißt, wir sind alles vor dem Viertelfinale und vor den Dingen, die dann in Berlin passiert sind. Aber das, was dort in Leipzig mit den türkischen Fans, mit den österreichischen Fans und dazwischen natürlich auch ganz viele deutsche Fans und noch ein bisschen Fans von verschiedenen anderen Nationen, was dort passiert ist und was dort möglich war, an fairen Gesten, an sportlicher Stimmung, an wirklich nach dem Spiel Respekt, Bekundungen einander gegenüber. Die Türken haben den Österreichern gesagt, was sie für ein tolles Turnier gespielt haben. Die Österreicher haben gesagt, wir waren heute vielleicht ein bisschen besser. Die Türken haben es eingesehen, aber am Ende waren irgendwie alle friedlich und freudig miteinander. Das war etwas, was mir sehr, sehr, sehr positiv in Erinnerung geblieben ist. Dieses Spiel und dieser Tag dort in Leipzig, auch ums Stadion rum. Es gibt viele, viele Probleme, was Fußball in Leipzig und dieses Stadion angeht, aber das Drumherum ist einfach eine richtig gute Ecke. Du kannst da wunderbar noch nach dem Spiel dich mit Leuten treffen. Beste Grüße an dieser Stelle an alle, die wir so getroffen haben. Es ist wirklich vielleicht mein Drumherum-Highlight des Turniers gewesen, wenn ich jetzt ganz persönliche Sachen wie meinen Geburtstag und so weiter mal außen vor lasse.
Du, was dein Highlight ist, ist dein Highlight. Aber sehr schöne Beispiele. Joel, was war dein Highlight neben dem, dass du irgendwelche französischen Nationalspieler zum Fototermin geschickt hast im Akkreditierungszentrum?
Ja, witzigerweise hat das dann quasi die Folge daraus, dass ich diesen Spieler dann auf der Presse-Tribüne wieder traf. Ich habe es ja vorhin erzählt, ich war ja im Akkreditierungscenter. Im Stadion hätte ich eigentlich nichts zu suchen gehabt. Ich habe mir dann aber gedacht, ich suche diese Kommentatoren auf der Presse-Tribüne. Und da sie mich ja dann schon kannten, konnte ich mich dort hinstellen bei ihnen. Und ich habe das Spiel dann mit Michente Lizarazou's Kommentar im Ohr live verfolgt im Stadion. Und stand quasi mit dem französischen Fernsehen, mit dem Producer dort und war dann in das Team integriert. Das war, glaube ich, der schönste Moment, sodass auch kein Volunteer-Manager, der meinen könnte, ich hätte mit meiner Akkreditierung, die ja nicht die richtigen Zahlen beinhalte, auf der Presse-Tribüne nichts zu suchen und konnte dort fröhlich das Öffnungsspiel verfolgen. Das, glaube ich, war mein schönster Moment. Ansonsten, nein, extrem viele Begegnungen mit Fans aus allen möglichen Ländern, das Volunteer-Sein und diese Uniform, dieses Grüne, man ist natürlich weithin sichtbar. Ich habe unglaublich viele Fotos gemacht von Leuten vor dem Stadion, die mich immer wieder angesprochen haben, die gesagt haben, über etwas gefragt haben, mit denen man ins Gespräch kam. Das waren wirklich die schönsten Momente des Turniers. Wir hatten sechs Spiele in München, Deutschland hat einmal gespielt, wen hatten wir zweimal, irgendjemand nur zweimal. Also ungefähr zwölf Mannschaften, zehn Mannschaften aus zehn Ländern, Leute getroffen, mit denen Momente verbracht.
Rumänien müsste das Team uns zeigen. Deutschland nur hätte man das Viertelfinale gewonnen. Aber das sollte ja einfach nicht sein. Wie wir aber an deinem Hintergrund sehen, für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, da hängt ein Frankreich-Flagge und ein Spanienschal. Joel ist da offenbar flexibel aufgestellt. Dementsprechend dann auch herzlichen Glückwunsch zu deinem ganz persönlichen Erfolg bei dieser Europameisterschaft. Matthias, was wird bei dir hängen bleiben von diesem Turnier?
Ich habe die ganze Zeit darüber nachgedacht, was ich jetzt sagen könnte. Ich kann mich irgendwie überhaupt nicht entscheiden. Ein Spiel würde ich auf jeden Fall rausgreifen, weil ich eigentlich dachte, habe ich jetzt Lust, heute da hinzufahren, weil sie auch nicht so genau... Das war das zweite Spiel in Dortmund, das erste krasse Regenspiel, Türkei gegen Georgien. Ich hatte relativ viel zu tun und war am Tag vorher schon unterwegs. Ich dachte, ob ich da jetzt hinfahre oder nicht. Am Ende habe ich ein Spiel in Dortmund gesehen, aber muss das sein? Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass ich dahin gefahren bin. Ich habe mich einmal richtig nass regnen lassen, weil das war für mich stimmungsvoll. Das war von der Stimmung her das beste Spiel des Turniers. Wir haben Traumtore gesehen. Was war da los, Tobi?
Das ist eines von den beiden Spielen, in denen ich krank im Hotelzimmer gelegen habe.
Oh, Entschuldigung. Das war richtig tief in die Wunde.
Es tut tatsächlich noch ein bisschen weh. Aber erzähl ruhig weiter. Alles gut.
Ich kann noch etwas tiefer bohren. Der Kollege, mit dem ich unterwegs war, sagte, das Einzige, was noch fehlt, würde ich voll unterschreiben, war eine rote Karte. Das hätte noch letzte Würze gegeben. Das war irgendwie ein tolles Spiel. Als ich dann so abzeichnete, es gibt die Möglichkeit, hier ein bisschen näher von dem Turnier zu sehen und das wirklich geklappt hat, dann auch in allen zehn Stadien zu sein, das war dann irgendwie eine Art von Freude, tatsächlich Dankbarkeit, dass das funktioniert hat. Leipzig, schließe ich mich total Tobi an, war ich auch mein einziges Mal bei Österreich-Dürkheim. Sehr interessantes Spiel, tolle Stimmung und in der Stadt super gelöst, habe mich auch verkehrstechnisch oder so, das war irgendwie fast der beste Eindruck dieses Turnier, was Leipzig da abgeliefert hat. Habe ganz spontan einen Beitrag gemacht aus Leipzig, wo alle irgendwie Zeit hatten für Interviews, das hat irgendwie alles super funktioniert. Und dann als Krönung habe ich Menschen wieder getroffen, die ich vor zwei Jahren in Katar kennengelernt habe, die Iraner sind, in die Vereinigten Staaten ausgewandert sind, weil sie geflohen sind aus politischen Gründen, in Katar kurz festgenommen waren, weil sie Women Life Freedom T-Shirts getragen haben. Die habe ich damals interviewt in Katar. Und wir haben immer Kontakt gehalten, so ein bisschen. Und die sind, weil sie solche Sportfans sind, auch zu EM gekommen. Und die habe ich da in Leipzig wieder getroffen. Und wir haben uns ausgetauscht. Und das war irgendwie ein schönes Wiedersehen. Einfach hat mich echt gefreut, die nochmal wiederzusehen.
Das ist wirklich eine schöne Geschichte. Und Tobi, du hast noch schöne Fangesänge oder eben auch nicht angestimmte Fangesänge erlebt.
Ja, ich möchte kurz zurückgehen, quasi auf eure Nationalismus und Rassismus bei der EM-Tribünengesprächs-Folge, wo ihr über die Engländer gesprochen habt und die Schotten vielleicht so ein bisschen da kritisiert habt, dass jeder zweite oder jeder dritte Song gegen die Engländer geht, wenn sie dann was singen. Und als ich das gehört habe, dachte ich, die Engländer sind auch nicht viel besser. Also ich hatte immer das Gefühl, das ist so ein bisschen die beiden gegeneinander. Das ist so wie die Nachbarn. Also logischerweise sind sie ja auch. Aber die Nachbarn, die einander, sie können nicht ohne einander, sie können aber auch nicht miteinander. Und die Geschichte, die ich jetzt noch erzählen wollte, war in einer Straßenbahn. Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, es war in Düsseldorf. Einer von den beiden, also England in dem Fall, hat gespielt. Und es waren noch so ein paar Rest-Schotten, die noch nicht nach Home getakt wurden. Also ihr wisst schon, was die immer singen. Also die waren noch da und die hatten noch Bock, ein bisschen Fußball zu gucken. Und besangen sich nun gegenseitig in dieser Straßenbahn. Vielleicht fanden fünf auf jeder Seite. Und haben sich halt, sagen wir mal, wie es ist, sie haben sich gegenseitig durchbeleidigt, von vorne bis hinten, so gut man das halt konnte, mit den Liedern, die man so hat. Aber jetzt ohne aufzustehen und einander irgendwie dann auch körperlich was geben zu wollen. Und dann fing der eine von den Schotten an und sang über den Tod von Queen Elizabeth, die jetzt ja dann irgendwann doch noch gestorben ist. Und da ist einer von den alten Schotten, der neben ihm saß, ist aufgestanden und hat gesagt, halt stopp, bis hierhin und nicht weiter. Wir beschimpfen die Engländer durch und durch, aber wir machen keine Witze über die tote Queen. Und das haben die Engländer wiederum sehr, sehr positiv aufgenommen und haben das mit Applaus bedacht. Und dann haben sie ihre Geschichten weitergemacht. Also was ich damit sagen möchte, das ist eine sehr, irgendwie von außen zuguckend angenehme Fußball und vielleicht auch ein bisschen darüber hinausgehende Feindschaft, die sie da leben, aber die sie wirklich auf einem angemessenen Niveau leben, sodass sie, glaube ich, ganz gut beide Seiten damit leben können, dass das keinem zu doll wehtut am Ende des Tages.
Und das wirft ja auch nochmal ein Licht darauf, dass wir wirklich viele tolle Fans erlebt haben bei diesem Turnier. Ich glaube, das kann man generell so sagen. Also ich habe kurz noch überlegt, ob ich euch frage, was so eure Lieblings-Fan-Gruppierung war, aber ich glaube, dass das ungerecht war. Es waren so viele, also egal, ob die Rumänen in München, die Dänen. Ich habe alle drei dänischen Vorrundenspiele. Ach ja, stimmt, und ich habe alle dänischen Spiele. Das fällt mir gerade auf gesehen, denn sie sind dann gegen Deutschland ausgeschieden. Die Niederländer, die Türken, die Engländer, die Schotten, die Georgier, die Albaner. Also es war ja unglaublich. Die Österreich habe ich glaube ich gerade noch gar nicht genannt. Also unglaublich viele, viele tolle Fans. Ganz, ganz selten auch mal welche, wo man ein bisschen genauer hingucken wollen würde. Zum Beispiel auch bei Deutschland, muss man das ganz offen so sagen. Bei Ungarn definitiv auch. Aber klar in der Minderheit, das ist so schon festzustellen. Und das habe ich auch in der internationalen Presse bisher so vernommen, dass das einfach ein Turnier der Fans war. Und es wurde auch thematisiert, dass es eben ein altes Turnier war. Also so ein Turnier, wie es mal im Original State war. In einem Land, das gut zu erreichen ist. Alle Spiele in einem Land, in einem Land mit Fußballkultur. Das wurde, also ich habe jetzt gerade heute nochmal die Totally Football Show gehört zum Finale. Da haben sie das auch nochmal thematisiert. Und ich denke, ihr habt das auch gemerkt, Tobi?
Und es ist halt auch ein Land, wo viele Fans schon da waren. Also Deutschland ist ja ein Einwanderungsland, das darf man nicht vergessen. Nur weil da jetzt jemand vor dir steht im Albanien-Trikot oder im was auch immer Trikot, ganz oft spricht der halt einfach Deutsch. Der spricht feinstes Deutsch, weil er seit Ewigkeiten hier lebt. Und du hattest Albanien und Georgien genannt. Das waren so meine beiden positiven Fan-Überraschungen des Turniers. Also was ich von den Engländern kriege, wenn ich mit denen irgendwie in Düsseldorf in der Altstadt bin, das kann ich mir vorher überlegen. Aber Georgien und Albanien, das waren die beiden. Und vor allem Georgien, die ich dann in Hamburg gesehen hatte, bei diesem 1 zu 1 gegen Tschechien, wo sie einfach in der 93-Minute die Chance zum 2 zu 1 haben. Und oh mein Gott, was wäre das fantastisch gewesen. Dann wären die quasi weitergekommen. Aber das sind sie dann ja am Ende doch, weil sie Portugal 2 zu 0 geschlagen haben. Auch in einem fantastischen Abend und einem fantastischen Spiel. Also viele, viele gute Leute kennengelernt und gute Leute getroffen, die dann auch wirklich betont haben. Das waren jetzt zum Beispiel Albaner, die gesagt haben, es ist für uns, hier in Deutschland zusammenzukommen, als ein Land, wir sind einfach in ganz ganz viele Regionen und in dieser Welt verstreut. Ich sprach mit einem, der aus New York, der ist aus New York nach Dortmund geflogen, um dort das Spiel der Albaner gegen Italien, wo die nach 22 Sekunden das 1 zu 0 schießen und einfach die ganze Tribüne auseinanderfliegt. Der sagt, das ist so schön, so viele andere Albaner, die irgendwo entweder aus Albanien oder Deutschland oder dem Rest der Welt hierherkommen und unsere Kultur auch auszuleben, Tänze aufzuführen, die sie sonst... In Düsseldorf haben wir das lange beobachten können, wie sie da einfach, für mich natürlich völlig fremd, aber fantastisch faszinierend und sehr, sehr interessant, ihre Kultur ausleben können, so wie sie es sonst vielleicht dort, wo sie einzeln sind, nicht können, aber gemeinsam dann in Deutschland, bei dieser Euro konnten sie das. Und ich glaube, das ging vielen, vielen Fans so, dass sie sich wirklich gefreut haben, andere Leute aus ihrem Land in Deutschland wiederzutreffen und mir als jemand, der jetzt in Deutschland lebt, ging es so, dass ich mich sehr gefreut habe, viele, viele aus anderen Ländern hier zu sehen und mit denen einfach eine richtig gute Zeit zu haben.
Matthias, du wolltest noch was ergänzen?
Ja, weil du gerade dieses Spiel in Hamburg ansprichst, da haben wir uns offenbar auch zumindest nur verpasst. Eine Beobachtung von der Presse-Tribüne werde ich auch nicht vergessen. Georgische Fans mit Presseakreditierung, würde ich jetzt mal diplomatisch formulieren. Das waren zwei. Der ist den Uefa Leuten tatsächlich kurz aufgefallen. Einer, der stand nämlich direkt neben mir an seinem Schreibtisch und hat die ersten fünf Minuten einfach mit seinem Handy gestreamt oder mit jemandem telefoniert in der Heimat. Und der war so ein bisschen so, na, den müssen wir ein bisschen beobachten. Was macht der da und darf der das und was wird das hier? Und dann gab es diese Szene und da ist in Hamburg, wer schon mal auf der Presse-Tribüne war oder bei der EM bei der Presse-Tribüne war, da ist ein so ein Gang mit so einer Glasscheibe, wo man so vor den Schreibtischen entlanggehen konnte, mit so ein paar Stufen über die Kabelbrücken. Und da ist er quasi, da stand er für diesen letzten Ball und ist dann im gleichen Tempo wie der georgische Spieler beim Konter die komplette Linie auf der Haupttribüne neben dem Hergelaufen und ist, als der Ball über die Latte geflogen ist, fast, fast über diese Glasscheibe gesprungen und hat sowas von laut geschrien und auf diese Glasscheibe eingetrommelt, weil er dachte, okay, das war es jetzt wirklich für uns und das bleibt auf jeden Fall hängen bei mir. Das war echt faszinierend.
Ich fühle das komplett. Das war das einzige Spiel, wo wir wirklich richtig, richtig gute Karten hatten und in Hamburg genau für der Mittellinie saßen. Und auch da waren viele Georgia, die, ich weiß nicht, woher sie die, also, na ja, sie waren auf jeden Fall da. Und sie haben es auf jeden Fall komplett krachen lassen. Und genau das, was du gerade beschrieben hast, der eine ist einfach mitgelaufen mit diesem Konter in der 93. Minute, nachdem die Tschechen einfach die ganze zweite Halbzeit nur Druck gemacht haben. Und oh mein Gott, haben die am Ende, ah, das war, es war wirklich bitter, bitter, bitter. Ein unfassbar schönes Spiel, Georgia gegen Tschechien in Hamburg, wo man denkt, ach ja, ist vielleicht nicht so das Premium-Ding. Aber das bleibt auch in Erinnerung.
Und es gab höchst unterschiedliches Verhalten von Journalistinnen und Journalisten zu beobachten auf Presse-Tribünen. Das ging schon bei Nationalhymnen los, die mit voller Imbrunst geschmettert wurden. Oder, so wie im Fall von Lothar Matthäus bei Deutschland gegen Spanien, der die komplette deutsche Nationalhymne nochmal gefilmt hat. Wahrscheinlich hat er das noch nie in einem Stadion erlebt, dass die gesungen wird. Bis hin eben zu sehr, sehr lauten Jubel, aber da kannst du keine Nationen-Unterscheidung machen. Also ich hab, ich saß beim Spiel Deutschland gegen Dänemark neben den größten Deutschland-Fans, die sogar Trikots anhatten. Man könnte jetzt sagen, sie waren nur Social-Media-Redakteure für eine Nachrichtenseite, eine Sportseite. Ob man dann trotzdem sich im deutschen Trikot auf die Presse-Tribüne setzen muss, ich weiß es nicht. Ich hatte auch deutsche Kollegen, die beim 1 zu 1 gegen Spanien sehr laut aufgeschrien haben.
Aber wer hat das nicht?
Geschrien habe ich nicht, muss ich sagen. Mich schützt aber auch, dass ich dann immer schnell Notizen mache. Das ist ein guter Coping-Mechanismus. Aber das war wirklich sehr interessant zu sehen. Gerade bei Nationalteams scheint diese Grenze zwischen Objektivität, Neutralität noch mal deutlicher zu verschwimmen. Auch beim Rumänien-gegen-Ukraine-Spiel war das sehr, sehr auffällig.
Und da haben wir noch nicht über die Experten im Fernsehen gesprochen, die Grüße an Christoph Kramer und an Per Mertesacker, die beim Öffnungsspiel hinter mir standen und sowohl die Nationalhymne als auch jedes Tor eskalativ zelebriert haben. Wirklich eskalativ zelebriert haben.
Ja, also es gab viele schöne Momente. Ich ergänze vielleicht auch noch zwei, die ich hatte. Das eine war, ich muss das vielleicht noch kurz aufklären, also die Folge, die wir in der Mixed Zone aufgenommen haben, beim Halbfinale Spanien gegen Frankreich. Das hatte logistische Gründe, dass wir das machen mussten. Aber rein theoretisch nach dem strengen Uefa-Reglement wäre das nicht erlaubt gewesen. Ich glaube, es war insofern in Ordnung, weil wir uns extra in ein Eck verzogen hatten und ich darauf geachtet habe, man sieht in unserem Hintergrund gar nichts. Also wer genau hingeguckt hat, hat den spanischen Teambus gesehen. Aber ich habe extra die Kamera immer genau so gedreht, dass du nie irgendjemanden darfst laufen sehen. Vor allem nicht den Mitarbeiter, der dann das Bier in den Bus gebracht hat. Und zum Busfahrer auch, der sich da auch sehr drüber gefreut hat. Aber das war auch dann möglich, auch wenn es kritisch beäugt wurde. Das fand ich sehr schön. Mein Moment dieser EM, neben ganz vielen, war glaube ich tatsächlich dann beim Finale. Ich war sehr früh da, weil ich eben die Schalte zu dir noch austesten wollte, Matthias, dass es auch wirklich alles klappt. Und dann schreibe ich Steffi Bartschick, die ja das Finale mit Holger Dahl und Thomas Bräuch bei euch kommentiert hat, und sagt, Mensch, vielleicht hast du ja noch Zeit, dass wir uns kurz treffen. Kurz darauf klingelt mein Handy und sie sagt, ja, dreh dich mal nach links und dann auf der komplett leeren Pressetribüne, weil wir waren sehr früh da, steht sie tatsächlich 20 Meter entfernt. Und dann bin ich dort hingegangen, habe einen wunderbaren Plausch gehalten. Das war sehr, sehr schön. Und als dann Thomas Bräuch irgendwann seinen Laptop aus der Tasche zieht, sich hinsetzt und sagt, hast du Bock, ein bisschen abzunurden? Und mir dann in Premiere Pro seine schon für den BVB gebrandeten taktischen Szenen zeigt, seine Beobachtung zur EM. Es war, ich war im Himmel, Leute, ich sage euch, wie es ist. Es war ganz, ganz, ganz wunderbar. Das war sehr, sehr schön, irgendwann Thomas hier nochmal in den Rasenfunk zu bekommen. Das muss das Ziel bleiben. Und Matthias, du willst auch noch was ergänzen?
Ich will einfach nur noch, um die Geschichte rund zu machen, erklären, dass diese Szene aus dem Olympiashal in Berlin zwischen Max und Thomas Bräuch noch eine weitere Geschichte in Köln nach sich gezogen hat. So klein ist die Europameisterschaftswelt. Ich hatte eine Expertin bei unserer Finalsendung im Studio, Michaela Specht, die mit Max offenbar auch Kontakt hatte. Und wir haben dann zu dritt so ein bisschen geschaltet, also Max aus Berlin und Michaela und ich im Studio in Köln. Und als wir fertig waren, sagt sie mir, der Max schreibt mir gerade, er hätte noch so viel mehr zu erzählen gehabt. Wir müssen beim nächsten Mal länger sprechen, weil eben Thomas Bräuchte ja ein paar Insights noch mitgeteilt hat, die du spannend fandest. Und das haben wir dann ja auch gemacht nach Abpfiff. Also so funktioniert das dann irgendwie auch hinter den Kulissen, fand ich auch eine ganz schöne Geschichte gestern zum Ende dieses Turniers.
Ja, absolut. Und Michaela, die ja auch schon im Rasenfunk war, kundige Hörerinnen und Hörer des Deutschlandfunks, du wirst es sicher gemerkt haben, Matthias, dass ich immer Michaela gesagt habe und dann das Specht noch ergänzt habe, weil man soll sich ja nicht duzen. Das war ein sehr schönes Zusammentreffen, muss man sagen.
Ach, da ändern sich Zeiten.
Ach so, okay. Ich war mir nicht sicher. Ich dachte mir, da bleibe ich mal lieber noch förmlich. Und habe ihr dann aber gleich bei einem Nachrichtendienst unserer gemeinsamen Wahl geschrieben. Ja, also wundere dich nicht. Ich habe jetzt einfach deswegen immer von Michaela Specht gesprochen, weil ich nicht wusste, wie ich es machen soll. Joel, du wolltest noch was ergänzen. Jetzt kommt deine Geschichte in dieser Suchgeschichte.
Nein, nein, nein, ich wollte eine Anekdote, aber ich wollte auch noch kurz sagen, Thomas Breuch bringt mich auch noch zu. Der Rasenfunk ist auch für mich auf der Presse-Tribüne oft so ein Aufhänger, um Leute anzusprechen, die bei dir in der Sendung waren. Und mir sage ich dann, ja, ich kenne den Max. Und dann komme ich oft in so ein Gespräch mit den Leuten. Das ist immer ganz nett. Aber zum Thema Spanien, weil du gerade gesagt hast, dass Bier in den Bus getragen wurde. Und ich wusste es natürlich schon vorher. Und eine kleine Anekdote. Vor dem ersten Spieltag kamen die Busfahrer. Wurden natürlich auch alle akkreditiert. Und viele wurden ja von einem Münchner Autobus-Unternehmen gestellt. Und dementsprechend auch die Fahrer. Und der Fahrer des spanischen Buses musste die Mannschaft am Flughafen abholen. Aber seine Akkreditierung, da war auch was schiefgelaufen und musste warten. Und da habe ich ihn dann dazu gebracht, den auf den Hof des Akkreditierungszentrums zu fahren. Und ich zeige das Foto nur ganz kurz. Und so hatte ich vor dem Turnier das Vergnügen, mich in den spanischen Bus zu setzen.
Hast du den Platz von Cocorella ausgepfiffen?
Ich wusste noch nicht, wer er ist, bevor er ausgepfiffen wurde.
Ich habe das gewusst, wenn du hättest die Belüftungsdüse auf die höchste Stufe und so in den Nacken stehen können. Also ich glaube, allerletzte Frage an euch drei. Wir alle haben natürlich viele Erinnerungen mit diesem Turnier. Wir haben jetzt trotzdem nur an der Anekdoten-Oberfläche gekratzt, aber es sollte ja einen Einblick liefern. Weil ich auch weiß, dass viele Hörerinnen und Hörer genau diese Folge eben auch mögen, eben mal so aus anderen Perspektiven auf dieses Turnier zu blicken. Aber eine allerletzte Frage habe ich dann an euch alle drei. Tobi, du darfst mal gerne beginnen. War es denn aus deiner Sicht und aus deiner Turniererfahrung heraus ein gut organisiertes Turnier?
Jetzt tust du so, als wenn ich bei 27 Turnieren in meinem Leben gewesen wäre.
Du bist schon viel bei Fußballspielen gewesen. Das kann man glaube ich schon so sagen.
Ja, bei Fußballspielen definitiv. Bei Turnieren einmal 2006, 11 Mal 2016 und dann dieses Mal diese 21 Spiele. Ich kann das auf jeden Fall unterschreiben. Ihr habt das vorhin einmal ganz kurz gedroppt. Die Katastrophe beim ersten Gelsenkirchenspiel. Ich kann das komplett nicht teilen. Ich habe es natürlich auch gelesen. Es ist schwierig in Gelsenkirchen das Stadion wieder Richtung Innenstadt zu kriegen. Mit dieser doch sehr kleinen und sehr einfachen Straßenbahn. Das dauert auch ein bisschen, wenn alle gleichzeitig gehen oder alle gleichzeitig ankommen. All in all war das an allen Stellen gut bis sehr gut organisiert. Ich pack da sogar die Deutsche Bahn noch mit rein. Auch die hat viel an den Backen gekriegt. Die haben ihre Verspätung gar keine Frage. Ich habe vorhin noch einmal nachgeguckt. Ich bin während des Turniers 57,5 Stunden mit der Deutschen Bahn durchs Land gefahren, um zu meinen Spielorten zu kommen.
Das ist ja mehr, als wir gesendet haben.
Was sie in der Zeit alles hätte machen können. Ich habe meistens geschlafen. Oder je näher man sich dem Spielort wieder begab, hat man vielleicht ein Bier getrunken. In den 57,5 Stunden sind sicherlich auch 4 Stunden Verspätung drin. Gar keine Frage. Aber ich war immer überall rechtzeitig. Es hat immer alles geklappt. Ich musste nicht mit Sack und Pack dreimal umsteigen oder sonst irgendwelche schlimmen Sachen machen. Preislich war es auch völlig in Ordnung. Ich gebe dem Gesamtkonstrukt dieser Euro, sowohl das, was den Fußball angeht, was die Start-up-Geschichte angeht, als auch das, was die Organisation angeht, ein absolutes 2, wenn man in Schulnoten rechnen möchte, wie das andere Tennis-Podcast zum Beispiel tun. Ich bin voll und ganz zufrieden. Ich fühle mich an keiner Stelle verloren oder nicht gut aufgehoben.
Ich habe fest mit der 1 gerechnet. Deswegen musste ich bei der 2 so lachen, weil du so überschwenklich warst.
Bei der 1 bringt man mich dann wirklich noch persönlich zu meinem Platz und fragt, ob ich nicht noch ein anderes Bier trinken möchte als das Angebot. Das wäre die 1 gewesen. Da gibt es halt wirklich Abzüge. Liebe Uefa, bitte nicht nochmal mit denen. Mann, Mann, Mann. Es ist wirklich... In München, ich meine, habe jetzt zwei Leute ganz offensichtlich, die viel Zeit in München verbringen. Du trinkst vor dem Spiel leckeres Bier aus der Stadt und dann kommst du in dieses Stadion. Dann trinke ich halt kein Bier.
Ja, dann trinkt man tatsächlich kein Bier. Man musste generell bei der Verpflegung vorsichtig sein. Im Medienbereich gab es... Das haben immer die lokalen Betreiber, die sowieso schon in den Stadion ansässig sind, die haben das gemacht. Und das war meistens gutes Essen und auch zu halbwegs günstigen Preisen. Aber es gab offenbar Kategorien für Gerichte. Und das hat dazu geführt, dass du in München gabst als vegetarische Alternative einen veganen Humus-Rap. Und der hat 6,50 Euro gekostet, fand ich völlig in Ordnung. Und ich musste mir in Frankfurt, glaube ich, hatten wir nichts gegessen. Und da musste ich für meine Beleitung und mich, habe ich einfach zwei Käsesäme noch schnell mitgenommen und habe dafür 13 Euro gezahlt und habe dann darüber gelernt, ach, das war wohl eure vegetarische Alternative. Na, herzlichen Dank dafür. Aber gut, es war immerhin eine Gurkenscheibe auf dieser Käsesäme mit drauf.
Vitamine.
Die sind ja auch wirklich wichtig. Na gut, für dieses Spiel, es war Portugal. Portugal gegen Slowenien. Da war das tatsächlich wichtig, dass man durchhält. Bis dann zum Elfmeterschießen. Joel, fandest du, es war ein gut organisiertes Turnier?
Ja, ich würde es sagen wie Tobi. Im Großen und Ganzen lief es gut, kaum etwas auszusetzen. Natürlich sind bei so großen Events immer Dinge, die sich erst einspielen müssen. Das habt ihr ja auch beim Eröffnungsspiel erlebt, dass Dinge noch nicht ganz funktionierten, weil die Leute nicht darauf vorbereitet waren. Es ist noch nicht ganz ein Rädchen ins andere Griff. Aber mit weiterem Verlauf des Turniers hatte ich das Gefühl, es lief alles immer besser und es wurde auch entspannter. Die negative Kritik konnte ich nicht ganz so nachvollziehen, wobei ich immer sagen muss, was ich davon gesehen habe, war ein sehr begrenzter Ausschnitt hier in München. Ich habe natürlich auch noch den Vorteil, mit dem Fahrrad zum Stadion fahren zu können. Was hier in München beworben wurde, da gab es so ein extra Filmchen. Dann war es aber schon schwierig, sein Fahrrad dort irgendwie anständig zu parken. Da, liebe Uefa, da nehme ich den FC Bayern auch ein, lieber FC Bayern, da kann man echt noch was machen. Das ist ein Witz.
Eine absolute Katastrophe. Aber das ist ja, im München Fahrradfahren ist ja sowieso. Das ist ganz offensichtlich nicht erbeut. Aber bevor ich mich jetzt hier errege, geben wir lieber die Frage noch an Matthias weiter. Wie würdest du dieses Turnier einschätzen aus Organisationssicht?
Ich habe mich über eine Sache vom ersten Tag an ein bisschen gewundert, muss ich sagen. Und das war Größe von Schildern und Wegeführung. Vielleicht war ich da ein bisschen katter in meinem Kopf. Weiß ich gar nicht, wie ich das verwöhnt sagen will. Aber diese Schilder waren ja schon, wo die Eingänge waren, auch Medieneingang, da musste man schon relativ nah dran sein, um zu sehen, wo das jetzt ist. Dann gab es diesen kleinen Container. Klar, es gab Karten, man konnte den vorher gucken, habe ich auch gemacht. Aber es war nicht so, dass man diese aus Gerüstbaustangen hochgezogenen Türme hatte mit so fünf Meter hohen Planen, wo in Schriftgröße 400 drauf stand, Medien links rum, Eingang A rechts rum oder so. Das hat mich ein bisschen gewundert, weil ich dachte, das wird in Deutschland ja auf jeden Fall garantiert sein, dass die Wegeführung irgendwie so ist, dass alles finden. Im Endeffekt hat es ja dann auch ganz gut funktioniert, aber das war echt so ein stetses Wundern, und es war in jeder Stadt auch gleich, dass diese Schilder relativ klein waren und relativ kleine Schrift auch drauf hatten. Ansonsten muss ich auch sagen, Deutsche Bahn, toll, toll, toll. Ich habe auch so eine ähnliche Statistik wie Tobi. Ich habe nicht gezählt, wie viele Stunden ich in der Bahn war. Ich habe Kilometer nachher hochgerechnet. Das waren bei mir 8.000 während dieses Turniers. Also einmal. Einmal. Ich bin nach Südkorea mit dem Zug und ich hatte eine kumulierte Verspätung von geschätzt zu vier bis fünf Stunden. Kann man sich jetzt in vier Wochen Bahn fahren, bei der Kilometerzahl nicht beschweren, glaube ich, in Deutschland. Also ich hatte eine Zugfahrt, die hat irgendwie zwei Stunden und eine hatte mal eine Stunde und sonst war es immer nur im Kleckerbereich. Also das war völlig in Ordnung. Also ich bin organisatorisch auch total fein mit diesem Turnier, mit den kleinen Abzügen in der B-Note, also mit der Zwei kann ich auch mitgehen.
Und sehr schön, dass du zuerst mit der Größe der Schilder anfängst. Das ist am ersten Tag aufgefallen.
Jetzt, wo du es sagst, ich habe auch oft genug gedacht, warum. Also ich war zwischendurch, weil die wollen uns jetzt was zu tun haben müssen, Tobi. Also ich habe dieses Schild in Leipzig, da steht so ein riesengroßes Ding, was so tormäßig war. Also es war genug Platz auf den Schildern, definitiv. Aber man hat einfach eine viel zu kleine Schriftgröße gewählt. Und mir ist es dann, als ich in London war am Flughafen, da kannte ich mich halt nicht aus, da ist es mir aufgefallen, wie hilfreich es ist, wenn die Schrift einfach groß ist und ich schon aus 20, 25 Metern Entfernung erkenne. Richtig falsch. Und natürlich ist es mir als Fußballfan gar nicht an den Stadien aufgefallen, weil ich in jedem Stadion einfach schon oft genug war, als deutscher Fußballfan und dort genug die Spiele gesehen habe. Das heißt, ich brauchte die Schilder nicht. Aber klar für Externe, das war nicht gut.
Okay, dann muss ich vielleicht noch die peinlichste Geschichte erzählen, die mir bei dieser EM passiert ist. Ich war beim Spiel Slowenien gegen Dänemark. Das war mein erstes Spiel in Stuttgart. Und ich musste schon früh da sein, weil ich das 15-Uhr-Spiel dann im Stadion sehen wollte. Dann das 18-Uhr-Spiel, dann eben vor Ort im Stadion und dann zwischen dem 18-Uhr und dem 21-Uhr-Spiel schnell in meine Unterkunft und dort das 21-Uhr-Spiel, um dann meine Sendung zu machen. Also so sahen mir die Vorrundenspieltage vor Ort manchmal aus. Und ich habe den Media-Hub nicht gefunden. Also es gibt einmal den Pressekonferenzbereich und den Mixed Zone-Bereich und dann gibt es den Media-Hub, das ist quasi da, wo man arbeiten kann, da wo man auch was essen kann, da wo man auch die heiß begehrten Wasserflaschen bekommt, die man dann selber wieder auffüllen kann, dort vor Ort. Und ich habe und ich habe ihn nicht gefunden. Und die haben mich, ich habe insgesamt, also ich habe dann auch sehr schnell gelernt, du musst die Orangen in Stuarts ansprechen, weil das sind die Chefs von den gelben Stuarts. Und zum Teil, dann stand sogar einer mit mir im Fahrstuhl, und ich so, komm jetzt fährst du mal hier mit runter, ist es hier auch nicht? Ich so, nein, siehst du es denn hier irgendwo? Aber der Pfeil zeigt doch nach oben. Also ich weiß es auch nicht, was ist schon da? Und dann ging aber das 15-Uhr-Spiel los und dann ich ab in den Pressekonferenzbereich, weil da hatte ich Internet und da dachte ich mir, okay, dann stream ich eben dieses Spiel und arbeite hier. Dann sitze ich ganz allein in diesem Pressekonferenzbereich und schaue mir das 15-Uhr-Spiel an. Und dann kommt ein sehr netter, sehr nett, schwelbesprechender älterer Herr zu mir und meint, sie wissen schon, dass man auch Arbeitsplätze hin, oder also ich kann es nicht, aber er hat es sehr, sehr charmant gesagt. Und ich so, ja, ich weiß, aber ich finde die nicht. Und er so, ja, das ist doch kein Problem. Soll sie eine Mitarbeiterin rüberführen? Und dann habe ich gesagt, na ja, ich bin ja eigentlich schon älter als sechs, aber wenn die nichts zu tun haben, dann können die mich gerne in der Halbzeit rüberführen. Jetzt muss ich erst mal arbeiten. Und tatsächlich war es dann so, in der Halbzeit standen zwei Volunteers, standen neben meinem Platz, haben gesagt, sollen wir ihnen den Platz zum Media-Hub zeigen? Und dann haben sie mich rübergeführt und Gott sei Dank ist uns dann auf dem Weg dorthin aufgefallen, der eine Pfeil hat in die völlig falsche Richtung gezeigt. Als ich das nächste Mal in Stuttgart war, war der überklebt mit dem Pfeil in genau die andere Richtung. Dann meinten sie, ach so, deswegen sind sie da hochgegangen. Ich so, ja, genau, weil da der Pfeil war. Aber tatsächlich habe ich mich wie ein Sechsjähriger an der Hand von zwei Volunteers, also nicht an der Hand direkt, aber zum Media-Hub führen lassen. Und da waren dann all die Leute, die ich auch schon kannte, die alle akkreditiert waren für dieses Spiel. Also da hätte es vielleicht auch eine Schriftgröße, größer hätte da nicht geholfen, wenn es falsch ausgeschildert war. Aber es ist ja alles gut gegangen. So wie diese Sendung eine einzige Freude war. Ich danke euch sehr. Es war meinerseits nicht geplant, dass es so lang wird. Ich weiß, dass ich das immer anhöre, wie eine Lüge im Rasenfunk. Aber es war wirklich nicht geplant. Umso mehr herzlichen Dank euch, dass ihr euch nach einem anstrengenden Turnier und ja, ihr habt auch alle noch andere Dinge jetzt zu tun, die Zeit genommen habt. Herzlichen Dank an Tobi Rieger. Hört die Sport-WG, meine Sport-WG, wie heißt es jetzt? Nein, die WG mit, die Wohngemeinschaft mit Tobias und Andreas. Wenn ich in der Stimme von Andreas sage, dann kann ich es komischerweise.
Die Wohngemeinschaft.
Also hört diesen Podcast, er ist sehr, sehr gut und da bekommt man noch mehr Anekdoten von diesem Turnier zu hören und hat sie zu hören bekommen, inklusive Ausflug nach Wimbledon. Das ist ja eigentlich das frechste von allem, dass du das noch in diese 21 Spiele EM reingepackt hast.
Ich hatte Sehnsucht nach Andreas und musste dann auch noch mal zwei Tage zu ihm. Der war ja 14 Tage in Wimbledon und dann musste ich ihn ein bisschen besuchen. Das war der einzige Grund, sonst überhaupt nichts anderes.
Nein, warum auch? Ich wüsste auch nicht, was in Wimbledon sonst toll sein sollte. Aber ja, also vielen Dank, dass du hier warst und hört alle in die Wohngemeinschaft rein. Ich werde es verlinken. Danke dir, Tobi.
Max, vielen Dank für die Einladung. Es war wie immer ein großes Vergnügen und vielleicht warten wir diesmal nicht acht Jahre, sondern nur vier.
Ja, du, besuch du die Turniere. Ich werde die nächsten nicht mehr besuchen können. Ich werde dann alles machen, wie bisher. Für mich war das die Aufnahme. Und danke, danke ich sehr, sehr herzlich, Joel Guyot, schön, dass du mit dabei warst. Danke, dass du ein paar Interne mit uns geteilt hast. Und ja, ich bin dann schon sehr gespannt, wenn wir uns dann wieder beim FC Bayern sehen und du mich in den Pressebereich reinlassen kannst. Du bist immer der Einzige, wo ich nicht darauf achten muss, dass dein Gesicht nicht im Livestream zu erkennen ist, wenn ich bei Instagram gerade live gehe in der Halbsamkeit. Weil bei dir weiß ich auch, du bist da entspannt. Also Joel, vielen Dank, dass du da warst. Das freut mich sehr. Und herzlichen Dank an Matthias Friebe, der neben all seinen Pensungen was abzureißen hatte, jetzt auch noch hier war. Matthias, es war schön, dass wir uns manchmal persönlich gesehen haben. Noch schöner, dass du jetzt hier in dieser Sendung mit dabei warst. Nee, noch schöner, das klingt falsch. Also mindestens genauso schön, dass du auch noch in dieser Sendung hier mit dabei warst. Danke dir, Matthias Friebe vom Deutschlandfunk. Genau. Also und so stellt man sich den Auftakt in den Urlaub wahrlich nicht vor. Deswegen herzlichen Dank dafür. Und dann danke ich auch euch, lieben Hörern und Hörern. Es wird noch eine Folge zu dieser EM erscheinen. Beziehungsweise vielleicht ist es auch schon zu dem Moment, wo ihr das hier hört. Im Nationalteamspeed gibt es noch den sportlichen Rückblick auf dieses Turnier. Ansonsten war es das jetzt mit der Berichterstattung zur Europameisterschaft der Männer hier im Rasenfunk. Sollte ja auch irgendwann mal reichen. Ich kann euch noch einen Veranstaltungshinweis geben. Und zwar werde ich am 23. Juli eine Lesung in Eckenfelden haben. Da könnt ihr gerne vorbeikommen. Geht es wieder um den deutschen Fußball und Uli Hoeneß. Und ansonsten danke ich letztlich natürlich auch besonders euch für eure Aufmerksamkeit, für euren Support während dieses Turniers und auch generell für den Rasenfunk. Ich bedanke mich bei David, Simon M aus L., bei Cara, bei Markus, bei Dirk und bei Jens Brümmer. Sie alle sind Rasenfunk-SupporterInnen, sind auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclubgegangenund haben uns dort unterstützt. Via Kreditkarte oder Paypal geht das oder via Überweisung. Und auf kiosk.rasenfunk.de gibt es noch bis Ende Juli den allerletzten Merch zu 50% Rabatt zu kaufen. Kauft ihn bitte, alles weg. Und dann bleibt gesund, bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk.
Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.